greetings from podcast Ville it's
Thursday January 10th the Church of
what's happening now is brought to you
by Robin Hood Robin Hood is an
investment investing app that lets you
buy and sell stocks ETFs options and
kryptos or Commission free they strive
to make Financial Services work for
everybody not just the wealthy learn how
to invest as you build your portfolio
uncle Joey's gonna hook you up with this
ok Robin Hood is giving the church
family a free stock like Apple for the
sprint to help build your portfolio sign
up at church Robin Hood dot-com that
church dot Robin Hood com
the church is also brought to you by my
bookie
listen and effect playoff for here
basketballs here it's time to get in on
the action with my bookie don't be that
guy that's that's got no rooting
interest as your relatives and friends
sit around watching the game not this
year not this year not Superbowl 53
around the corner it's really the most
of the year right now you got college
hoops starting you got to play all you
got basketball you got hockey what that
means is you can make some money so do
me a favor go to my bookie right now and
offer you a 50% deposit bonus to make
sure you got a nice bankroll for the
bowl season use promo code Church when
you deposit to activate the offer again
go to my bookie you play you win you get
paid you understand me
number two the church is also brought to
you by 23andme we now live in a world
where we have access to the data that
gives us more personal insights on who
we are from how we we came from how well
we sleep how many steps we take per day
should not help resolutions be
customized also 23andme
allows you to go beyond ancestry to
access more personalized insights based
on your DNA from health predispositions
to your lifestyle choices what I'm going
to do is this ok Bar you 23andme health
and ancestry get that
at 23andme comm / church again that's
23andme dot-com / Church again 23andme
dot-com / church take this [ __ ]
muley the machine in the [ __ ]
house Happy New Year brother dear Joey
how are you I feel [ __ ] phenomenal
you got the demise Eugene is still on
Mickey Mantle I got the Mickey metal
Dean's flexing right now Yeah right yeah
I'm happy I'm [ __ ] dude I go for I
start my tour tomorrow oh my god I've
never been more excited for some I
couldn't sleep last night I was excited
to be on tour and you know how it is
what it is is we travel so much just do
a stand-up and you'd watch people you
know like usually in the all community
would be like this is my tour and you're
like it's just the road that's what we
do it never ends but this [ __ ] tour
it has like a finite time out there and
I'm like oh hell yeah I'm just gonna go
hard as [ __ ] for four months and and
just and just go and this is everything
you work for in this business to do a
big theater tour do it in hit New
Zealand Australia Europe dude all I
can't [ __ ] wait you taking the family
aunts flying out tomorrow looks like of
the tour bus so the ants coming out and
where she's stocking the tour bus making
sure it's got everything that I need
like he's gonna buy blender by like
sheets and blankets and stuff chargers
lock it down and then I'm on the tour
bus all weekend this weekend Portland
Seattle Calgary Vancouver and then come
back for two days and then I'm gone for
the rest of the month so you fly the
Seattle I fly that I fled Portland with
the ant tomorrow morning okay and then I
take the bus yeah two shows two shows
every night I'm just I'm really excited
I've always wanted to have a tour bus
I've always wanted to be this and I
looked at it this way you know how
you've always taken in people people
with you on the road and so you've
always kind of had a family like a
community and going with Joe I never did
that I always let the oh I always like
tried to foster the communities of
comedy that I went to so I was like if
I'm going to Omaha I'm like bringing a
good local feature cuz he's gonna let
him get the work you know that's you
gotta be give back to the community
that's ooh idea that you do that to
certain markets I bring somebody yeah
and there's certain markets I know it
has a good crop or feature acts yeah and
so and so sometimes it's great and then
sometimes it sucks and then the weekends
long and you're doing your ad in shows
and you don't know the guy and you're
not hanging out maybe he's got issues so
this year I'm taking I'm taking guys
with me we're all staying on the tour
bus together and I looked at it it's
just a party we have taken week hey Zeus
Trejo offering a murderer a murderer
Shane Torres okay Dave Williamson and
Dusty's I just got damn it I always [ __ ]
up Dusty's name I think it's dusty Slade
I don't think it's done switching them
up yeah switching them up so it's like
one week on one week off for them and
they'll fly in on Thursdays and leave on
Mondays and then I'll probably on couple
of them I'm staying on the bus because
we've added a Monday show and then no
Tuesday's show but we're doing a
Wednesday show so I'm just gonna stay on
the bus and drive to the next city and
it's great dude I got the girls are
gonna fly out and do a weekend with me
and stay on the tour bus they're
bringing two friends because I got six
bunks so I have four little girls
hanging on the tour bus and they're
gonna love it they're gonna fly in
Friday night
grab them Friday night they'll come go
hang on the tour bus will drive Saturday
go do something fun during the day
they'll hang out that night Saturday
night and come home Sunday main taking
your family Europe with you girls are
coming to Europe but all the girls come
to Europe and Australia with me yeah but
we're gonna go so I'm like the European
tour I'm gonna have them fly out to
London or Paris maybe maybe Paris I've
already been to London sure Paris is
such a safe place yeah that's what we're
gonna hang out for like a week and then
I'm gonna start the tour and they're
gonna come to like the first venue but
in same with Australia Australia I think
I go to like I do Sydney and then I'd
know I do New Zealand and then I have
like a like four days off and so they're
gonna meet me in Sydney and we're gonna
do some stuff in Australia I can't wait
you'd not be any of this I thought I
thought about it but I didn't want to
turn it into I I wanted to enjoy the
moment I'm gonna be on Instagram a ton
you know that and so like I'm [ __ ]
all over his too
so I'll put it on Instagram I'll
probably shoot my own stuff you know
like shoot it edit it put it on put it
on YouTube and then I'm gonna do I'm
gonna set up a podcast on the bus so I'm
gonna do some podcasts with people like
Dan Diamond Dallas Page we're doing a
podcast in Atlanta so it's gonna be work
to but I dude I can't [ __ ] wait the
only thing that would make this better
and you know we've always talked about
this it's like me you Tom re Joe all us
all it's doing a tour like that together
that would be the [ __ ] that would be
the dream you know but until that time
until the time when that happens this is
what I'm doing how much easier do you
think it's gonna be for you do not have
to fly to go to the airports just to be
on the bus [ __ ] that can I tell you my
favorite part that's amazing
that is when I did when I did Australia
last - last year I was burnt Joey to the
point where I was like I was fried cuz
you know me I drink if I fly so I have a
couple drinks before we took off have a
drink in the air land try to get some
rest go to the theater do the show and
that was every single [ __ ] day and
that's what this tour would have been
like two shows in Portland I get done it
130 right with my meet and greet I go I
get back to the hotel room at 3 I'm
still poppin because of the show got a
flight at 6:00 in the morning I would
have been I would have died Leanne
pulled the plug when they started adding
shows then goes [ __ ] this someone quote
out a tour bus he's gonna die if we put
him on the road like that and so I can't
wait that here's the best part right so
I'm bringing in two suitcase full
clothes right and I'm leaving him there
I'm leaving them all on the bus so that
when I fly in to fly out I just like
when I fly out for a Vancouver I just
show up a pair of sweatpants remember
we'd switch over to sweat pants show
with a pair of sweat pants some headsets
my phone a jacket my wallet I'm done no
suitcase no [ __ ] nothing just walking
into the airport with it on your phone
just tink like walk right through fly
home go straight home you got all your
clothes at home all your clothes on the
tour bus dude it you know I watched
Ralphie do that tour bus and it made no
sense to me cuz I was like I was like
but other than he was fat and but now I
look at it and I go oh that's a nice
feeling to know that you got a home on
the road and then a home at home
wait man so funny bird how when I got
here in 97 I stuck around for a while
and then I hate the bag of dicks and I
decided that I needed some more road
work but I really needed to go and hold
my crap and I I would leave for 10
months yeah I would leave and November
come back in April I would ship my
clothes
Josh Wolf's house wherever I would go to
a city to have a good Kmart I would buy
new clothes and ship to clothes yeah you
know I had the walk walking with the CD
player and I learned how to live on on
and I did this is when I did plane and
plane plane and trains and buses I'm
sorry I only did one train from Miami to
Myrtle Beach but everything else was
done on a bus I loved it yeah the like I
said unknown for me it was really
unknown that because there was no dates
there was no there was no internet at
all it was no no I would start with like
January 10th and I'll pass on and I'd
have a week off and then then have a
week in Toronto that have a week in
Miami and have three weeks off when I
started it was like that but as I went
along every week I picked something up
yoder had a fall out Milwaukee improv
umhum the whole Green Bay improv no they
used to be a green band for real yeah
who goes to it you know in the summer
time they're not gonna go watch you yeah
and the wintertime they're eating cheese
watching the [ __ ] package I think
about yeah how do you with the Green Bay
dude that all right I remember that I
went religion no they don't want to know
about comedy they just want to tackle
people nobody wants to Green Bay talk
about that do you know when was the last
time you talked to anybody who said I
did this theater in Green Bay and it was
fantastic
I'm doing Green Bay on this tour are you
really yes the first time yeah I love
whatever
I've never been to Green Bay in my life
I was I took a fall out in October yeah
and they actually had the ball to do a
Sunday show and I heard and they won
that week plus my buddy played for Green
Bay at the time yeah so I could talk
[ __ ] I went to we played his name was
Frankie winters and we played CYO
basketball together so I did okay yeah
it's the people that you go to Green Bay
on a Sunday game Saturday night before
they have a game they're animals yeah
back then when Brett Favre was throwing
touchdowns you couldn't you know there's
just some cities that calmly just you
know what yeah we like the ha ha and hee
hee yeah but we're here to tackle
[ __ ] like we don't we just
think about football I thought I was
gonna be like that you ever done the
blue no no I everybody says it is phenom
shooting special in Hawaii yeah they're
[ __ ] gorgeous shot a special on
Hawaii yeah what jo koy Gabriel is there
this week I thought it going down to
Hawaii I was like they were like booked
me in Honolulu at the Blu no are you
doing Montana on this tool no again
nobody goes to Billings
yeah Billings just sit there waiting
like a virgin like right now if I had my
last handful of money and open up with
comedy call them Billings because I know
I know I would get my investment back
that quick that quick it's overwhelming
it's like what this guy is doing in Utah
what what's he doing in you guys have
three comedy clubs each Stubbs who I
love who's now the club wise guys is
becoming one of the best Club best clubs
in the disgusting country in the country
Utah Salt Lake Mormons don't go to
anything you got nine wives what are you
[ __ ] kidding me everybody wants to
laugh yeah so pretty soon watch
somebody's gonna pop Billings Bozeman
one of those towns in Montana and it's
gonna be blue
didn't you tell me about Spokane -
Spokane's [ __ ] go the tri-cities
those are the tri-cities yeah and
something else was the Tacoma the comas
on the other side I've been I've been
identical Mattel I like that when you do
uh
this years ago there was a lady called
Donna Richards and she booked on a
Portland she booked a volcano
there was an
Hotel and it was in some part of Oregon
but it's on the other side opposite
Portland real close to this so this
Spokane and another city is all you have
the civilization yeah so they called it
the tri-cities my god when I moved to
right before I moved to LA I started I
met a girl at that volcano role Friday
night we swapped a little spit and she
came back with her girlfriends on a
Saturday night
we swap swap the little spit I was a
gentleman I think we thought we took it
out ain't a monkey but no sex there was
no condom and I go back to Seattle on
the phone won't stop ringing it's his
brother
and she's really pretty the girl was a
[ __ ] knockout really sweet and one
day were fourth of July she drove up
from wherever she lived three hours away
and me her Josh wolf and Malia and
Josh's kids mother you know have like a
4th of July party they're like what a
nice girl and I'm like ok and something
was wrong with me I had seen this girl
like 8 times and I never went for the
monkey like she was that hot yeah
we had swapped spit we had gotten hot
and sticky from time to time but we
never really did anything and one night
were on the phone having a conversation
I go yeah next thing I gotta go to San
Francisco
she goes what what do you think if I
Drive you and I go that's ok you want to
drive him like oh my god she wants to
try and me I had to rent the car yeah
she saved me 400 [ __ ] box I go if you
wanted and I didn't think like I think
now like you think when you're 40 I
think well I was 30
it's a ride I don't know what I'm
getting myself into
you know I enjoyed that sure enough she
shows up on time cool or sandwiches
sundress looking like a goddess and as a
driver the San Francisco at one point
something comes up about a [ __ ] and
she looks me straight in her face and
she was you know I'm really good at does
you know
[Music]
we get for the hotel we'll say oh I'll
be the judge of that
it's like Monday night open mic at the
plancha mano Sunday night was the
punchlines and Monday nights was cobs
when that scumbag was up there and he
would make you sign your name our list
and he wouldn't tell you what time you
go up and then he just come up to you
and tap you on the shoulder you know how
many comics flew into that open mic and
he didn't put up no no he told you on
the phone he was who was his luck he
quit he quit he was an old guy that ran
Cobbs real prick and he was the one that
told Ralphie why the Joe takes re and me
on the road that we were worthless and
we used to bust Joe's balls and he had a
crush on Joe because one day Duncan and
and re went downstairs to the radio with
Joe and that guy purposely brought a
two-seater he told re and Duncan he
couldn't go so Ralphie told me the story
I told Joe Joe's I come on the guy
wouldn't say that I always knew the guy
was a closeted psychic forced on us so
for months every time we go to Cobbs
like Tom how's your friend Joe I would
just told Matt Joe Johnny and he wants
to suck your dick like he would come up
I go Joe you want me to say like I would
just like I'm gonna say yeah you I'm
gonna stay I don't know what's going on
between you two and Joe was taste my
gang a dog trust me I know but that dude
was a scumbag and then used to run an
open mic on Mondays before cops burned
down there's a Jewish lightning the
first one really the first one used to
be down to call in a warehouse by the
Chocolate Rain the Harvard Square
Guadalajara swear what is it know what
they would show up yeah I've been
watching too much narco and then up the
[ __ ] horn and now it's up to call it
but he looked they live on they tried to
live on fire whoever owns it to try to
get Jewish lightning and they moved yeah
but it was then and then the guy at the
punchline his name is on the tip of my
tongue he also told me on the phone when
you tell a young comic you're gonna put
him up on the open mic and you have a
reference prick Raisa
oh I love birds yeah Burt called come
down Sunday
forget him - yeah you would get there
and say what do I sign up and he goes
there's no list I'll put you up when I
want then he turns back on you and walk
away and you just stand there
you just stand there all [ __ ] night
and he come up to you at one point and
go you're up next
I said I'd give you six dude three and
you're like I got a [ __ ] hotel room
for $40 that I had a beg and borrow for
almost like a guy and [ __ ] you
willing to me three I mean that's what
they'd those two closing the tourists
let her [ __ ] her I said something to
that guy and you don't mean I was crazy
I had to say something to him like hey
man what the [ __ ] do you think you are
to pick us you know we don't have it
hard enough then he'll get the [ __ ] out
and I left and then I saw him a year
later at the Laughing one the night
showcase I was showcasing and he was
there with a bunch of in those days San
Francisco would come down six guys and
they would set up a showcase of Jamie
Masada and Jamie would decide who would
make it and then kids from Portland
would come back yeah I caught him out of
San Francisco on and he was bitching in
the back they wouldn't put his guys on
I'll never forget walking up to mom and
me [ __ ] did you see that 20 yeah
and here you are sweating like a [ __ ]
pig don't feel good does it ain't just
[ __ ] beamed of me and I never saw him
again
I always that he's been out of the
business for 20 years snatched a scratch
he had one of those [ __ ] singular
cool names you know Seth all those
[ __ ] it it's nice it's nice I mean I
guess it's nice when you see people that
treated you like so much [ __ ] I said I
go to go past them but I have such a
[ __ ] needy personality that even the
people who treated me like [ __ ] once
then once they come in like hey man
Congrats whenever all the success I go
hey thank you so much I really
appreciate it like I have a hard time
like I don't I don't think there's been
that many people that have been complete
and total dicks to me I let bygones be
bygones
let's it's the situation to me feels
like this you ever have that girl from
you dated in college you actually keeps
in touch with you yeah every time you go
to Tampa
you take her out to dinner with her
husband and your wife and you're looking
at it and the whole time your own
giggling ha ha ha ha drinking whatever
wine but you lookin like that [ __ ]
gonna and when I used to tie you up and
make you suck my balls like a savage cuz
you're looking at him he's like at least
kissing her you're like hey we love each
other
yeah she loved me till I whip the wood
about than May the same [ __ ] I miss
all my nut sack that you know I'm saying
like you you know you won like this
guy's trying to be a nice guy be like
what shut up I used to [ __ ] her in the
ass with egg yolks and so much better
when you do that and you come see me you
know what they're playing like you
believe this [ __ ] dirty [ __ ] she's
an animal
it feels like when you see those people
who doubted you know yeah even though
you're cool with them yeah now you got
the upper hand
yeah but I always sued her and I always
talking about this everything feels
fleeting always like everything
everything like like the first time I
did first time first time I started
selling tickets I remember calling Tom
going like how long do you think this'll
last [ __ ] I don't know man I feel the
same way like you always feel like I
don't do you ever feel like you got one
over on people where you're like I know
I know I think I'm funny but I didn't
think anyone else would ever think I was
fun all the time yeah I always thought
this Comedy Store last night I wasn't
last night to the store I did the main
room and I sat in the original room and
I watched like four or five comics and
there was two or three room particular
that I go I don't [ __ ] get it I don't
get it there's been fun that's lame for
me that to judge or whatever I just
don't get it but there's people who say
the same thing about me
you know yeah we all live I definitely
say it about me I tell people all the
time that we all start at zero on the
first of the month you and mainly raw
legal law legal and you know you don't
know what's gonna happen you don't know
what's gonna happen and all you could do
is do a good job that's why I don't like
[ __ ] getting in the way of my stand-up
anymore yeah when I go on the road it's
to do those five shows nothing else I
might go to a kickboxing class I might
do a jiu-jitsu class I don't know he
want to hang too much I don't really
want to get involved in longer rides I
focus on the comedy I won't even sell
[ __ ] no more
really yeah I can't see I don't want to
be outside in between two shows there's
enough mayhem going on in the hallway I
just want to go in and give him the best
show I could give them so no matter what
they think when they walk out maybe I'll
get them to come back next time it's so
funny wherever I just maybe it was Omaha
who you just an Omaha no whoever I just
was maybe Virginia Beach or I forget
they go one of the kids comes up I do a
meet and greet for both shows it's just
free dogs pay for it and um one of the
guys goes like you think you're cool
like Joey Joe doesn't do a mean greet
but like on The Late Show go go on hang
out yes you can go out and talk between
yeah just causing chaos
yeah I'm just causing chaos for the
staff and that 9:30 show now becomes a
10 o'clock show and that I think it's
more uncomfortable when I go to a show
it better [ __ ] when you go to the
movies this has never been a [ __ ]
late the movies ever late no no the
commercials run late you got 10 minutes
to play and put Parmesan cheese on your
[ __ ] popcorn at Laemmle and whatever
the [ __ ] you do yeah then we got a run
on time too nothing bothers me more when
I hear about a comic doing three hours
and people gotta wait on the line
outside for two hours me I ripped the
tickets up when I go home oh yeah hey I
have plans I have [ __ ] to do Sunday and
this comic wants to do three [ __ ]
house nothing bothers me more about the
comedy club that starts late nothing cuz
there's actually that second show
because every minute that's late it's
it's one more minute that the headliner
struggles that's one more minute that
they can have another shot of tequila
that's one more man that they could do a
line of coke every [ __ ] minute that's
why there's clubs I love my staff but I
can't work with them now because they're
on [ __ ] late time 7 o'clock to 7
20 now that means already now it's a
sold-out show so guess what that show
don't start no quarter to [ __ ] 11 11
o'clock
that means we're there till 12:30 that
means that there's people are so excited
to see Bert Kreischer that they started
drinking at 5:00 know this Bert I did
you know a couple weeks ago they were
doing a thing called the house fast okay
I'm 50 you're 40 the thing starts at 12
you and I both know we're not showing
the new years a New Year's show at
midnight yeah it's it goes to admit I
think Ozzie came up at midnight but it
started at lunchtime by 4 o'clock I
could have taken bets for puke puddles
from how many people started at tanjung
getting overexcited when people come see
us they get overexcited every one of us
I had a guy having 4:20 in Columbus the
guy [ __ ] had a seizure from eating
edibles and they wanted to cancel the
show the show must go on his friends
wanted to see me so bad that they told
him he's going to hospital by himself
and they stayed there once the help they
came in with a [ __ ] hospital room and
they took him out like a bed you know I
remember going to concerts that's why
we're meeting ever Christ you at 5:00
and doing lines of coke and a half a
quaalude and by the time you get to the
country you're out of your [ __ ] mind
dude that's every you know I'm counting
on this club to be on time I get 705
yeah I'll cut back five minutes show
I'll cut lead down to five whoever's
working with me down to seven
but that Late Show has got to start on
time hmm because if not it comes out of
the headliners hide some guys to say
something they're hammered damn it
that's not fair to you and that's not
fair to them so imagine going at Denver
and doing two hours and it's snowing out
and people gotta wait for you it's the
experience that blows I'll have a Casey
improv and I'm on stage I'm hearing
thunder and lightning and that's what
for the first show and so I go to do my
meet and greet and I'm like hey
where's uh where's the next show at and
they're like the waiting in line
everyone was waiting in the [ __ ] rain
yeah and I just went hold on wait you
didn't we didn't think this out better
no like oh they're just standing in the
[ __ ] right and everyone came in
soaked in [ __ ] wet and I was like
holy oh we didn't feel how would you
feel yeah I would I would have I would
have burst a lot they should have a
lounge they should have put those people
in yeah they should have a [ __ ]
lounge so those people are going and
have a drink I don't want nobody outside
Watley what do I tell you I don't care
this in' like ari said to me the other
day oh you're gonna be in New York for
Danny Brown show I'll come up to
Williamsburg there's a barbecue place so
people stand on the line for now oh not
gonna see me that yeah you're not gonna
see me there unless I get a Jewish
[ __ ] gold chain I get one of those
neck braces like phil leotardo and The
Sopranos
after he got rear-ended you wore a neck
brace that's extra money because the
neck brace makes you cut the line we
never feel bad feeling like a dog with
you dude I can't wait in line I can't
wait you know what else I can't do I
can't go to a place where you got to
grab a table like where they're like
we're like people I like standing over
tables where people are eating waiting
for them to leave and then they get up
and they sit down there that gives me
[ __ ] so much anxiety what do you mean
like we're like you know Californian
chicken Kiev at Cafe where there's a
line of people right and then all the
tables are full but there's still a lot
of and there's no seating you gotta find
your own table and get your own table
and and people are just like like just
hovering over tables with like waiting
for them to get up and want take it up
they sit down in their seats and like do
we got this table that gives me so much
[ __ ] anxiety so some that's kind of
wipe the table off where you sitting
yeah yeah you know no one's gonna be
clearing tables like if we go to the
barbecue restaurants were there there's
not always there a long line but then
this there's not a ton of tables so
there's too many people in line for the
tables they have so the second people
are waiting for a table so once they get
up then people just go down and sit in
that table that gives me so much [ __ ]
well the waitress comes over sit down no
like you got a Californian chicken cafe
I think he's talking about places where
like you go up your order they give you
the food and you go sit down they'd like
there's probably not a waitress
oh yeah there's no waitress the thing
that I think it's even hard for me to
understand because anytime I get to go
on the road it's probably my first time
in the city so I'm very excited you guys
have been to every city how many times
now 15 times you've been I go towards us
14 so definitely 14 times and that crazy
I've been too [ __ ] I've been to
Philadelphia what 14 did you perform
where have you not performed it the only
place I have not performed it is there's
two states Hawaii in some notes
everywhere else
I got Hawaii I got Alaska oh good yeah
shoku Charlie's I haven't done like
Vermont like that like there's a bunch
of what ever did Vermont either I can't
lie to you like all up there I never did
in New Hampshire I did other one when
Maine Maine when the Bob Marley club was
up there the Comley connection he owns
that territory I did I did all Buffalo
Hobley the Buffalo I've done all that
stuff Rochester Syracuse never done
Mississippi yes I did Mississippi
Mississippi I did all the southern
states I got that out of the way just to
make sure I've never done it I'd like to
do Mississippi have you ever done the
Alabama stardoll yep just did it how was
I loved it
really yeah but Leanne's from Alabama so
I had a bunch of jokes like diodes I was
dialed in because they have written that
Club walk I really started doing comedy
that was like the top five clubs in the
country now they say it's a little I
think a lot of a lot of the clubs I mean
from my perspective and what and this is
just what people have told me and like
the work of the clubs is a lot of the
clubs are urban a lot of the clubs are
all just black comics coming through a
lot of the funny bones
that's all they have their whole lineups
are just black comics and I think the
stardome is one of those places where it
just sells it sells better to the to a
black community that it does to a white
people because I think guys who used to
do that Club jumped up the theaters real
quick in that area like Bilborough I
think we used to do that Club all the
time and then he left up two theaters
and then guys like segura just went in
and go well fine I'll just do a theater
there because that's what they're
accustomed the
I think but uh but yeah a lot of the
clubs at want have gone urban are you
ready for these theatres are you excited
about doing these theaters and whatnot
yeah does it feel differently do you
feel the difference from the stage to a
theater I'll tell you the only not I
don't feel a ton of difference but I
changed I changed my stand up a tad bit
and got less crowd interactive when I
think probably two years ago where I
used to lean on audience interaction
when I was younger man I just get up on
stage and I was like I'll do the first
teeth 15 minutes [ __ ] around with
people and then I'll they'll be like my
I can go back to them every time I need
a joker you know I'm talking about
Reggie and and I stopped doing that I
stopped doing that and just started
working on my material and probably four
years ago three years ago and so now
when I do theaters I'm much more
comfortable I couldn't do theaters when
I was younger because I was I didn't
know how to not do crowd work I gotta
say he said we're friends a long time
I tell you how it is I don't give a [ __ ]
yeah I'm getting salted your Netflix
special was sensational I was waiting
for you to insult me it was in the top
five
thanks Tony I'm very much in my heart
that's number one thank you more but you
have no idea when you say that move
miracle eyes me because you made a big
jump in your standup there was years ago
I saw you one night I'm like Bert's got
problems like I left there like you had
no shirt on you're three koalas in the
wind I don't know what the [ __ ] you were
talking about and then I saw you a
second time and you had done a complete
360 you had talked about eyelid and
going to school and you know she's not
the bright one and definitely better da
and then I see you a couple weeks ago
and you're flipping on me again with a
gun and you pointed the gun at your wife
you know then you or the machine gun and
the specialist sensation or you know
Roseanne's LeAnn's faces when she's
[ __ ] and all that yeah just just
little things that you really worked on
I saw and that's I have a bad habit
that's a bad habit as a comic just
talking to the audience it's all really
bad guess who's really good at who me
yeah I was about to say I will do it
yeah I remember seeing you I've never
seen you talk to the audience a long
time ago probably like 11 years ago with
the improv and and you were there I
think you were big then and you were
just hands up here and I forget the
[ __ ] interaction but I'm in the back
sitting next to in bag whose amazing a
crowd work and we are rolling I'm really
[ __ ] that role I was lazy yeah I
wouldn't write material my first no
after I left Boulder I Beach when I got
the Seattle I went to New York that's
what happened in 93 I went to New York
and I got impressed by everybody in New
York talks for the other dude where you
from your garbage man's back my land oh
my god what's this no like [ __ ] so I
picked up that habit in New York that's
why I picked it up and I kept doing it
and doing and doing that I kept
depending on it so I would have a
30-minute set but I would do I would
really have 16 minutes of material yeah
and I would depend on 14 a crowd work
Meeta ISM it's like shooting dice if I
shooting dice you could kill a show so
my goal was to go in there improvise it
and then close the work material and it
got a little better but it was still
laughing yeah I'm when I came to Iowa
was weird dude totally different you
better not say a word to the audience or
for them it's you sure to never less
you're spectacular like Rick Ingraham
you better not say a word and you could
see when a comic moves from another town
where they have that bad habit in fact
the guy hit me up a few days ago it's a
dear friend of mine he lasted because he
was opening up with that [ __ ] so how you
guys doing tonight it's great to be here
in LA I bought a big round of applause
for the troops that kills that way crowd
I have nothing against the troops I have
nothing against celebrating la just
doesn't work
away and then he started talking to the
audience and they will he do for a
living on the guys like oh my god he did
it at the improv dude and it was a slow
death and I tried to help him out cuz he
was a dear friend of mine and I get I
had brave that so I gave him a spot prey
of the following week and he went down
the brand he did the same thing and it
was the longest feat just part of my
life and when he got off he told me some
story about his relative getting sick
that he had to go back and watch I know
it took him a week to break no I think
10 days I know another guy that came got
an apartment moved into it for a week
went to the improv went home packed his
bags then went right back to Mexico they
stood those calmly and every two years
up me up with a face book some type of
email hey man I should have stuck with
it too I'm [ __ ] sorry I went out when
I got out here I had a TV show I've
moved out from New York I had those New
York tendencies of crowd work first
crowd work first it murdered in New York
New York ground work yeah they love that
you could do they love it yeah yeah yeah
and so I get out and I and I all my TV
shows are done I hit up Aaron at The
Improv and say no I need to really get
on stage I need to be on stage as much
as possible I'll do anything so I'm not
getting any stage time at the time she
goes well Drew Carey is doing Wednesday
nights
I need a host to do 10 minutes and then
bring on drew Carey he's gonna do
stand-up and then they're gonna do whose
line is it anyway so I'm like awesome so
I get on stage and I'm a verse first
thing I said on stage guy in the front
row I said what do you do sir because
I'm a TV producer I went what really I
got anything I know and he goes
everything you know and I went Wow can
you get me a job because I don't know
man won't you tell a joke first and I
was like and I Joey I didn't have I was
like in my head I was like I need a
Puerto Rican enter the room missile a
[ __ ] head dog I didn't have any
[ __ ] jokes I didn't have one joke I
had a couple stories that I could like I
could like but like I
know how to do setup punch I needed
someone to feed me some energy and then
I could feed it back with a with a joke
and I remember I bombed so hard and drew
Carey what was not in the room and but
he walked in at the room at the end and
I had I had one joke that I told at the
end that kind of did okay and Drew Carey
came up and he goes uh great job man
I'll see you next week he didn't see me
bomb and so I did that every week and I
that night I went home and I wrote jokes
I wrote just like like just anything
that was a straight-up setup punch I
wanted something that would get me out
of trouble like something that was like
I'm trying to remember one of the early
jokes I wrote but uh you know what cops
hate when you touch their faces like
just anything that was set up to get it
get me out of things and then and then
when I went on the road I was I got back
into that lazy habit of like you just go
up and crowd work with murder and and
you could and I am man I'm telling you
I'm telling you right now I swear to god
that shift in my career was that that
machine story when Joe said Joe so this
is one of my favorite memories in this
business I'll ever have Joe said you
know you got to tell the hosts age I was
like aw it's not a staged story because
no no you have to and everyone listening
right now this is this is like episode
60 of the Rogan experience he's like
everyone listen right now you yell it
out in the clubs until he tells it you
make him tell that story on the road
call him the Machine from now on he's
only to be known as the machine that
next weekend I was in Columbus Ohio I do
a set it's fine not memorable I don't a
lot of crowd work a lot of [ __ ] with
the audience take killing a beer shirts
off and I get I get to the end of my set
and this kid in the front rows they're
yelling the machine and I go hey guys
I'm not gonna tell it and it's kid in
the front row I don't know who this kid
is he was an angel he looked at me he
goes hey Bert you got to tell the story
man we understand it's not gonna be good
but you got to tell it and and we'll sit
through it but but you got to tell it if
it's gonna get good so just just tell it
man and then everyone's like yeah Bert
just tell it just tell it it's Joey I
bombed from 15 minutes telling my
machine story and I got done and they
were all right at the meet-and-greet
they're like hey you did a good job you
got to tell it next show man you gotta
tell it next show I told that store
for I want to say four [ __ ] years
where it just bombed like it but once I
did that I learned I figured out how I
could write for myself I didn't I didn't
need you these like there there was
these cover all I'm gonna say this I
don't mean a disrespectful but there was
a cover all Dane Cook approach to comedy
that a lot of us guys took a lot of us
guys had those jokes like you know it's
fun to do when you walk into a room you
do this that and then tell your buddy
punch him in the dick and you like yeah
what's that I'm out [ __ ] and that was
like the premise of writing jokes you
know it's I had a lot of them a lot like
you know happens when you do you know
you do here and I find what you were
wives 12 words say I love you you are
right you win I love you whatever then
you go back in bed with her and that and
I watched she's sleeping you cut her
hair like it was almost like fun boy
comedy and I did I had to departure from
that fun boy comedy and I really started
an NRI I think ari got obsessed with
storytelling and he started his
storytelling show and you could go in
and tell a story and and it was a
different way to write for yourself that
shifted everything for me and now I look
at light now I look at it now I'm
looking at material and I'm going like
you know you look at the Waber and Rogin
and and and all the greats you know they
challenge themselves every special to do
be a little different right a little
differently ad ad maybe an act out or a
new one like when I saw wrote and I'm by
the way I've never known Joe to be like
a physical comic but when I saw him do
that pterodactyl bit with Bruce Jenner
or Caitlyn Jenner and and be on the
state on that stool and I saw that all
sudden it freed up my head like oh I
don't have to just stand in deliver now
I can do whatever the [ __ ] like but you
look at your did you watch the bat all
you wanted to store this bad [ __ ] dude
he burnt a thousand calories
he's his new special is gonna be [ __ ]
it's a thousand [ __ ] calories dude
he's been one of the biggest comics in
this country one of the top 10 earning
comics he hasn't had a special out in
three years all that shit's just off
Showtime [ __ ] Shaw Showtime when hate
when his Netflix special drops yeah I
don't know what the [ __ ] gonna happen
when ISO four shows at the garden that's
just mine do you remember
remember when we were younger and you go
can you imagine adding a show
can you imagine selling out a weekend
just selling out a weekend at a club
this heats to 30 that was like a [ __ ]
big achievement and then we're all there
we're all selling out clubs and then you
look at a guy like Sebastian four shows
at the garden that's 80,000 people
80,000 people know who Sebastian I'm
gonna be dead on us I don't know if I've
sold 80,000 tickets on this entire tour
like every club every theater I'm doing
like 1,800 a thousand you know like in
between they're 80,000 people in two
nights and what could they do in Chicago
like two nights later do it this is what
I'm saying dad that is [ __ ] and from
such a unassuming garden what if you had
the opportunity to do Madison Square
Garden there's a comic would you do it a
hundred percent I don't know if I would
Oh Joey
Oh Joey I just if you could sell out the
garden just to have that moment where
you walk on stage and you just I would
die because I grew up in that place -
can you imagine the Harlem Globetrotters
not going because my birthday's on
February 19th it always lands on the
President's Day so from the age of 4 to
13 I made my mother take me to home love
try this every my mom was so annoyed
time I was eight she started paying
somebody - oh he did the garden came out
as mellow lark Meadowlark lemon just in
a Harlem Globetrotters outfit I went to
see something there that I I never felt
I want to see it arrange your island
again yeah and then a week later I was
there for Rutgers against North Carolina
and basketball when [ __ ] I think know
Michael Jordan wasn't there Michael
Jordan wasn't even dreamed of that it
was Michael Coren and so Ford and
Rutgers had James Bailey I used to go to
the garden to see Julius Erving
Christmas Day against the Knicks I mean
you understand my history with this
place I saw ac/dc open up for Ted Nugent
at the garden I saw Keith Richards and
the [ __ ] new barbarians at the garden
I you know it's so for me to just walk
in there and perform like I don't know I
don't know if the stand-up thing would
get lost and you know I know
that's what scares me about all those
big things that's why I asked you
earlier about how do you feel in a
theater compared to a club this is a
theater tour and I'm probably did a ton
of work and you deserve it thank you
do you like cops for example yeah I love
the people who run jobs I have nothing
against them I don't like performing a
cop's I don't have control over my
audience at tops I know you said had the
punch line I could fix Michael it's a
hundred and eighty people you can just
whip them if they talk and shout out
yeah I think yeah and bits labem there's
audio this rooms where I have control of
the audience
we'll have you done the parks Casino in
Philadelphia no it's a theater it's a
casino [ __ ] perfect really like
although there's a bunch of rooms that
are big but they still give you that
small feeling the wilberth things I was
just gonna say them well but either you
think you're at [ __ ] Johnny's Mambo
room yeah you think you're in front of
200 people you did in front of 28 people
but then you look up and you go I'm not
even look at that I just care the
heights the first time I did the Wilbur
I went up I got I went I had never done
a theatre I've never done that like
personally never sold a theatre and so I
go this is twice three years ago I go up
yeah probably three years I go up to the
to the thing and I want to go up to the
top and see what it looks like from the
top openers on stage I go all the way up
to the top and I look out I'm on the
very top balcony and I get a copy at
tito's and soda right I got in my hand
I'm doing one show I'm looking over I'm
like oh this is [ __ ] amazing
and then I realize and then someone
Bert and I go yeah she goes oh my god
it's Bert and then everyone in the top
Center was like you're the guy we came
to see and I'm like oh I guess I can't
just hang out in the [ __ ] balcony but
that is an amazing I had ly amylum Lee
and the next time I did it Lee Ann came
with me and I sent Lee Ann up I'll go
walk around like take a look at this
place
Chicago Theatre is pretty insane that's
three thousand and that place there's a
bunch of places I'm like excited to do
like the Tabernacle in Atlanta like I
just I'm like I'm [ __ ] can't wait I'm
doing the Tabernacle this year I'm
looking at when you're in Boston
you're really sold out for chosen Boston
right yeah they're already sold for yeah
I think so so it's you know it's weird
because they go that's sold out but then
it's the single seats available so
people just definitely pay it's sold out
and then they pay this 50 tickets left
today yeah it's just a thousand stories
it's just a bat vancouver's sunday night
like bow shows sold out and then they're
like hey we've added we've added a
hundred tickets to both shows I was like
well hold on do I need to sell those and
then I care if you want to I was like
how many ways you add them from there
like it's it gets really confusing
especially like ticket pricing and all
of that
cuz there's ways I I wouldn't mind
taking pricing to go like I wouldn't
mind a consumer meaning like if I went
and saw your show and you say you could
get any seat or you can pay a little
extra to say let's sit on the aisle I go
all pay extras upon the aisle if you
could go you can also pay a little extra
you get in first I be like oh yeah
definitely I want that too
like hey what else can I add on to this
like that's why I also have a trying to
set up a meeting with Ticketmaster to
talk about a way to price my tickets
cuz there's certain things that as a guy
who would go to a theater that I would
like like to sit up front
I wouldn't mind paying more money but
then I guess they say that that really
[ __ ] with you presale because your
presale is all like when you go on
presale for these theater tours that's
rewarding your fans like the people to
follow you on Instagram lists in the
podcast that's they buy them in presale
because you're not it's not released to
the general public it's just you going
there on sale right now if you're a fan
of mine this is the reward you get as a
fan is like I'm let you know now you can
go get set up front for the exact same
price as the guy that sits in the
balcony so but you
there's I think there's I'm curious to
see their to see how this works you know
it's a first like legit big theater to
where I've ever done and I'm I'm
interested to see I'm interested to see
how certain material goes over you know
I'm interested to see if I can [ __ ]
around as much as I do in the clubs like
cuz I can workshop a joke in the clubs
and get away with it and then the
theater I don't know when you got 1800
people like you said you got it whip
them into shape and make sure they're
listening so uh okay I'm trying to
figure out the wait staff raffle I got
something going on with that I wanted to
be a party bro
I'll tell you what I did last night then
this is um this isn't well the kids
Oxnard said he won the raffle yeah wait
staff guy said he you game 800 bucks
whatever do you thin a few there's no
weights that I got an idea okay I got an
idea yeah cuz in the theater they sit
they have to go all the way to the back
and get a [ __ ] beer there's no way
staff and [ __ ] theater you know I'll
tell you what I'm doing okay by the way
I haven't thought this out fully this is
just I and if it ain't if anyone's
listening this doesn't happen the way I
want to for whatever legal purposes just
know that this is where my head's at
so I had a really hard time with the
meet and greets cuz I know I like doing
mean greets I think it I like meet and
greets like if I went and saw you I
would definitely come up to you and go
hey man I thought you were [ __ ]
amazing there's part of me that is that
guy
you know like if I see a band if you
told me I could meet Jeff Jeff Tweedy
after a Wilco show I'd be like oh please
what I'd pay anything but I don't want
to have people pay to come see me do a
meet
I'm not gonna charge like 300 bucks to
go come backstage and meet me because I
feel like that's not our fans you know
our fans are the ones that are literally
like hey man I'm gonna dip out on my
Netflix bill next month to make sure I
can go see Joey live or Joe Siebert or
Tommy live so what I'm gonna do is and
by the way don't hold me to this but
this is what I'm doing I'm trying it
tomorrow night in Portland I'm going to
raffle off I'm gonna put a raffle box up
front you get a ticket you can buy as
many tickets as you want everything
that's a dollar and at the end of the
show I'm gonna have them backstage pull
fit
ticket numbers and each of those 50
people or 25 whatever the number comes
out to be can bring a plus-one backstage
and say hi and take a picture all it
could all it matters is they raffle off
that get that number all you need to buy
is one ticket for your chance to win you
can buy more tickets if you really want
to do it and then I'm gonna take all
that money in the box
I'm gonna pull one of the numbers and
then just give that money to a fan at
the audio at the show who doesn't get to
come see you maybe yeah I just go and
you don't get a meet-and-greet but boom
here's your ticket you get all the money
for the raffle I don't want it I think
that would be dirty if I took that money
I don't I wouldn't feel comfortable with
that
but to give it back to a fan so likes
theoretically someone comes to my show
wins $5,000 how [ __ ] great would that
be and then the bigger it gets because
you know people I know me
I put 200 bucks in if I went oh [ __ ]
yeah I want to I want a chance to win
the money at the end of shows when
you're doing the tabernacle for 1,800
people you get you could do like pots of
40 grand
home security walk them to their car
stage you go you don't get the meet
agree but here's $10,000 bring friends -
yeah so I thought about that last night
excite so regardless I'll do the raffle
for the beatin Greeks I want it to be
fair to everyone and if you want to put
in more money the raffle but that's what
I think I'm gonna try it tomorrow night
in Portland on the first show and just
see how that works see what the right
number of meet greet people is so it's
not overwhelming it's kind of you can
run smoothly and then see if I don't
know how I don't know I talked to my
business manager about like if that's a
tax exemption or if I'm running a
illegal gambling rack I'm giving away 40
grand tonight so you know you know me
I'll videotape it I'll put it online and
we'll see how it works I'll be doing
that in Vancouver - shows guys will do
it we were doing it with the loonies for
two knees what are they called boonies
loot loot loonies and toonies right
yeah loonies and toonies it's it's
Canadian money it's $1 and $2 and it
smells like maple syrup regardless
is is that why part of the reason why
you're doing Oh big like a lot of dates
because for me like the part that was a
little not frustrating but hard I when I
did like a like the Fox with Joey is
it's hard to just do one show like I
feel like you don't like you've just
barely getting warmed up okay you're
doing a lot of shows like no no no the
plan was just to do one and everywhere
and then they sold out and then
immediately everyone's like well you
already there you want to add a show and
Segura was the first one I'm am I lean
on Tom so much I bust his balls
we both bust each other's balls a lot to
heat him all of all of us have been so
you're the one that got me out of Sunday
shows Tom's the one that whenever comes
to money always run to Tom go and see
your work and Sunday show so I didn't
get job no not this tour but Tom's like
that second shows where you make your
money when you add a show because you
got to rent all the [ __ ] they're there
already yeah you got to rent all that so
if you do one show you don't get the
lion's share but if you add that second
show all those expenditures are already
paid for
so the second they were like Haiti I
remember them calling me we want to
presale and like I'm gonna you know you
do a big radio tour so I get done the
radio tour like 7:00 in the morning
girls or two probably 8 9 in the morning
girls are in school I go to take a
shower I'm gonna take a nap and LeeAnn
comes in and they're like you sold out
Boston
I was like wait it was just one on sale
like an hour ago she goes yeah you want
to add a second show I was like [ __ ]
yeah and then Dorfman called me and a
Brian Dorfman and he was like hey man I
think I'd have a good tour and then that
afternoon like noon they woke me up and
they're like hey they want to add like
13 second shows and I was like okay cuz
you're like you're already there you
make that money in then you're like okay
this will be a good tour and then we
added a second show to every [ __ ]
market when we'd four and some three and
some and but then but then it turns into
the thing where you that's where I had
to flip in my brain I can let this
overwhelm me or I can turn this into a
party and get myself a tour bus and just
go I'm not I'm not my goal isn't I'm not
gonna just try to do a cash grab I'm
gonna make this fun for myself and
really enjoy it and just enjoy it like
like I like if you told me 20 years ago
hey man you're gonna do a world tour
we'll get you a tour bus and you can
bring your friend you can bring some
really great comics to open for you
I'd be like oh this is how I want to do
it and so I was like that's how I'm
gonna do it and I'm gonna enjoy it and
so like I think in st. Louis I'm staying
for a Monday night show we're doing a
Monday night show I think maybe in
Minnesota too and then and you just like
[ __ ] it man
I'm in I had a flip of my switch - I did
I think I didn't eight or nine shows in
Brea the other weekend I just said hold
on don't get overwhelmed by two shows
just this is the job yeah I like to show
ya
I like to Judith I also like Thursday
night I love going on on Thursday doing
one show doing a 15 minutes extra and
trying [ __ ] right and feeling out the
room that I do enjoy but I do enjoy to
show nights Sundays I had to give up I
don't care what you pay me on a Sunday I
can't do it normal that was the biggest
I can't I still I cannot sit there all
day and people you don't know what life
is until you're sitting there all day
you have Sundays but you and said you're
in this fall you're in the spring yeah
you know you don't want to be it's like
when I didn't will turn the [ __ ]
Yankees were in town like the do-over
and my Sunday Miami was coming in yeah
you know and they're like well why don't
you stay for a Sunday show
I'm not going hand-to-hand combat and
drunk people they don't know how much
you know millions they made that weekend
you're not expensive our hotel room was
yeah well 405 a hotel room because the
Yankees are coming to town
they [ __ ] I got you you know you have
to
I like touring but I don't like they on
my face yeah what's the first thing you
hear on Monday did you hear about this
guy he's [ __ ] in [ __ ] Florida what's
the first thing here on Tuesday [ __ ]
last time he was a the 13 tickets you
know everything I do I wanted to be done
a specific way it was perfect man you
told me that and I remember it
immediately you you if you have that
that Sunday show I mean just to put in
perspective for those that don't know
what we're talking about Thursday show
you're flying in for you're flying in on
Thursday no press all you do is land
take a shower or I know there's a lot of
people flying Wednesday night yeah but
that's a fortnight away from you
family I play my flying that what night
away from you earth you things for you
to be an effective stand-up comic which
for years I didn't do these things yeah
I wasn't smelling roses I was too busy
doing it and it won't wanna I don't know
why Terry's still with me because the
first three is I let her know to face
that she did not hold a candle account
uh yeah I don't give a [ __ ] about your
birthday Valentine's Day just my
birthday go [ __ ] itself then Christmas
wipe your [ __ ] with that and all that
[ __ ] because when you're a real comic
you don't think about those things
oh yeah when you're 30 years old you
have no responsibility no girlfriend no
wife no kids the holidays are over
people calling and yelling hi we're
coming to LA for 10 days that's great
what I'll see you Sunday night at the
4th wall what are you talking about I
thought we were going didn't go and see
Mickey Mouse go see Mickey Mouse or your
mother
that's what this becomes it becomes I'm
living away from my family
and if I'm doing this school the club's
every night don't start this is a Laker
game
don't do this I keep it when I was from
from 97 to 2003 I was not a very nice
person
oh I was not a very nice I was a nice
person but my focus is I don't go and
[ __ ] about Bert's birthday party Josh
wolf over here right now
I don't know what Josh wolf tie it asked
him if I ever went to any of his parties
with his cousin when Scott wolf with
every Saturday they had a party go ask
him yeah my job was to be a comic I
don't know what you're talking about
I don't know what you're talking about
yeah I catch an occasional Dodger game I
go to the beach once a year and you know
well how long were you talking about
it's like you can't you can't you come
to orange kind of daytime no cuz I might
get an audition yeah no how many times
you're on your way out to go dick around
and we'll send your agent calls they
want to see you at 2:30
they gonna come all the way back at the
fax machine get this I don't
do they know understands that Georgia
with Georgia was born on June 7th we
took her home June 8th and I left June
9th to go work I was like that's what I
do this is what you do yeah I I've evil
tube down on the sand and then they get
mad when [ __ ] don't flip you away you're
30 Lee you got no wife no kid far from
what you believe you don't need to sleep
you don't do anything you don't need to
be there tomorrow morning
you're a talent too it's a it's a it
you're a comic there's that old Jerry
Seinfeld story you told in comedian to
remember that does the a bunch of like I
see the comics bunch of comics or or
musicians or whatever it's a story it's
an old story I'm gonna [ __ ] it up but
this is the gist of it once you're late
late night acts like us guys who work at
night that's what they do their bus
breaks down in the middle of the in the
middle of winter and so they got all
their gear and they're walking on the
street when they walk up to a house and
everyone's inside the house like a
family and they're all sitting by the
fire having cocoa and watching TV and
one guy looks at the other and goes can
you imagine having to do that every
night because we got I mean I got I got
the best job in the [ __ ] world
this is you know I've been obsessed with
this lately but like I have a brain that
all it does is think about comedy all
day long all day long all I get to do is
think about comedy yesterday I was
laying in bed and all I thought about
was writing jokes about glory holes
that's it for an hour I just i reworked
at every angle i just lay it in bed and
leanne comes in she was what are you
doing and I go I'm working that's it
I called up Stanhope them this is one of
my best Stanhope stories that I changed
the way I started writing I called
Stanhope one time it's like sunset in LA
Suns already probably down in Bisbee and
I ain't answer the phone hey what you
doing he goes having a grapefruit and
vodka having a cigarette and trying to
think of some goofs I said what he goes
good thinking some goofs I'm trying to
run a knock-knock joke joke you know is
the beauty of this
job as you hang out with a guy like nor
McDonald and you watch his brain work
and you go that's all he had to do do a
bill burr and I were hanging out the
other day and he goes I can't just tell
you a joke like oh yeah it's one of the
[ __ ] funniest jokes I've ever heard
and he's yet nor McDonald told it to or
no Gilbert Godfrey told it to norm norm
told it to me
I just told it to you if those I thought
you'd enjoy it and you're like that's
our job that's our job is just a [ __ ]
think of jokes that's it oh come on I
love it I love the whole process of it I
love a tizzy I love this I love this we
I love pie today I love that I'm sitting
I'm sitting at where we had a meeting
right before this me Liana my mom and
appellant and they're the the guys
running late and so I text you I go I'm
running 15 minutes late
then the guy is like I was like I gotta
go I got a bounce and he's like whoa you
gotta get back to work and I go yeah
kinda and the guy what do you do I said
I'm a comedian and he goes that must be
nice and LeAnn cuz I was just going over
to Joey Diaz his office to do a podcast
and the guy goes you know Joey Diaz go
oh that's my afternoon that's my
afternoon is I just get to come over
here hang out with you guys [ __ ]
giggle and then go home have a glass of
wine get in the pool dial on I [ __ ]
love it dude I leave here pick up mercy
yeah take of the karate at 4:00 that's a
head boil spaghetti factory like a
Spaghetti Factory we go to a restaurant
on Wednesday night Italian food which is
God horrible yeah but she loves it I sit
through it and [ __ ] pray I don't get
simplest and we come home and I'm gonna
watch the yard Kelly thing what 10 years
ago I'd be doing for spottster Oh bro
that's I wrestle with that because I
understand well I had to stop wrestling
with it I wrestled with it this week no
conclusion this wheel conclusion you
gotta be at the store on Tuesday night
this week I said no I literally these
last couple weeks I know that I'm going
on tour hard they Jessica will give me a
text and be like Tiffany avails and I I
was like I'm trying to spend time with
the girls cuz I'm about to hit this tour
so and I told I told
I said you're not gonna see me for a
while and I can't I can't hang out
before the tour because once I'm gone on
the tour I'm gone and I want the girls I
want to be able to teach Georgia how to
slide I want to teach I want to you know
take the girls out do stuff I want to
see movies with them for a little bit so
I it was rough man I've been looking at
the lineups lately cuz I get him on
Instagram and I'm like [ __ ] I should I
should be there tonight I should be that
we fun it's just all bullshitting around
in the back I saw the other day was like
D'Elia Rogan and Tommy and I was like
and you and I was like ah I see the
pictures that trick Conrad posted and I
go [ __ ] I want to be in that green room
just [ __ ] and it's I can't do six
nights a week no no I mean I'm I'm sorry
I don't even know how I don't remember
falling asleep I got home like a quarter
to twelve [ __ ] around the office for
about thirty minutes I smoked some
[ __ ] pot I made notes or something
and then it felt like I was up all night
and then it was 5:00 in the morning and
then I had to pee and my wife was
already out of bed and then I heard the
door open I heard bye daddy and I got up
and gave her a chance of yeah I might
see you later and [ __ ] and I'm
embarrassed because I like being up
early so I woke up at 8:00 on the dot
7:50 was when she leaves for the school
but I can't do that five nights a week
yeah you know it was a day last week I
had to take like three naps in the
daytime without three days in a row like
I'm going on at night I just those gigs
in Oxnard and [ __ ] that's it that's why
I cannot I love my agents I love that my
agent has the ability to send me around
the world you want to get booked call my
agent on I'm going on vacation if you
tell them if you call Justin and Tom
you're going to Mars
they'll find you a job and Venus I told
them that's we've laughed about this
it's like the worst thing you could tell
my agent like call them I'm on vacation
where you going Connecticut an hour
later
listen I got you a date there I don't
want a [ __ ] date I just want to see
ya cuz when you go on vacation with your
family
and you gotta do a date it's usually
that night when you're having the best
time like you your mom is there yeah and
now it's 7:00 you got to get up from the
[ __ ] table and excuse yourself and
you can't cancel because this two shows
already sold out oh and you're like this
blows that is so that's why I do like
when I went to New York this last time I
didn't take the [ __ ] comedy show
nothing
yeah nothing I don't want to do nothing
I don't wonder that I remember those
days when we'd go to the Liana we have a
lake house in Alabama and we go there
and I'd get in the car and I Drive two
hours into Atlanta and do a spot at
night and then drive back and I am abhi
likes you really have to leave I love
that stuff yeah when that vacation [ __ ]
yeah I do
I don't want to do a gig for money is
what I'm saying yeah if I'm sitting
there and it's nine o'clock and the
in-laws are in bed I know you say you
don't want my life down bag committed to
the baby's tire and I'm sitting in it's
nothing on TV and there's a pizza place
that has an open mic you bet your
[ __ ] ass I'm gonna walk that open mic
get a slice of shitty pizza local comics
yeah why not that's phenomenal yeah one
thing that's one thing to be sitting
there and you go up to your daughters
and go you want play Monopoly no honey
what do you want do you want no I'm
gonna go do they don't sing in-laws like
oh we're tired yeah let me go see what
the [ __ ] is going on on the open mic
seen you walk down to the corner is a
coffee shop you open up that local
entertainment area and sure enough open
my poetry night I see poetry night I'm
down there on steak
I'll show you poetry when I get on stage
I know the other day that somebody told
me they were back to Boulder somebody we
were at the store somebody goes it went
back to Boulder you're not I believe
that they closed Penny Lane I was Penny
Lane and you ever have those things like
I don't know how to describe them I
think that they affect it's one of those
places in your life that when it closes
it actually does something to your heart
something memorable to you
candy store when you grew up at the
people home that the family the three
generations you know something for you
was a pizza play you telling me it was a
pizza place in your neighborhood then if
one day your mom causing those guess
what mr. margiana was closing the pizza
place you like really like that just
took the wind out of my sails that's why
I would go when I go home and I see Burt
you know when you go to Tampa yeah like
I go to Margie ah no I'm just making
Caesars Annie or for you yeah yeah down
in South Tampa had the best the first
place that taught in Florida we didn't
have pizza the way everyone else did but
I had New York style pizza with a crispy
crust and he throwing that you didn't
see places like that and he'd sprinkle
parmesan and an oregano on for you on a
cheese slice of cheese every time you
got the spinach and tomato and the
cheese that was it every time it's dude
Caesars in New York in South Tampa and
then I went down with my I was with I
think LeAnn the girls when the girls
were young or driving I go do you wanna
have the best piece of piece of you'll
ever have in your life she's like yeah I
Drive up to it and it's gone it's like a
[ __ ] [ __ ] kwik-e-mart for pills
now well this did something to my heart
Penny Lane was a coffee shop and bold
have you ever been the boat yeah love
bolder this is what it was this is
ninety eighty eight when it was very
hippie-ish so I got on stage in 91 I'm
trying to be a comic
there's no comedy in Boulder I wasn't
the halfway house with this dude that
was older if I was 30 he wasn't bit
about 50 was the whole bank robber or
some [ __ ] I think he's not a bank robber
he was a safecracker we even talked
about a couple times he told me how to
crank different safes and he was very
entertaining guy Jewish guy from New
York yeah he wasn't 50 but he had a
[ __ ] girlfriend that was 26 and just
bang and she was the manager at Penny
Lane Penny Lane was a coffee shop one of
the French coffee shops way before
Starbucks and behind it was the harvest
restaurant and Penny Lane they had poet
tonight and I would go there you know I
would because she would give me a drink
for free so I would go there put $2
nothing and she would give me like
Chohan coke or whatever and then they'd
be up there like so I ran and I ran and
I ran into a mush filled with roses and
all this stuff so one that I said TOI
don't listen do you mind if I go up down
and she's like I don't know the guy that
runs it thinks he's [ __ ] Shakespeare
I mean the guy really had the Hat with
the pack of a few yeah and everything
and I go up there and just unleash a
barrage seeing God's own jokes and
Chinese people running and they had to
cut the show like stop stop this is a
poetry night and I go you know what's
the difference just let me do three
minutes you know he's like well you're
insulting some of the people I go on
[Laughter]
[ __ ] and Chinese people running away
just sound like a nice guy he goes just
do me a favor come to the midnight one
there's a midnight one on Fridays and
Saturdays they would stay open all night
this is when it was safe yeah
don't you how many times I went there
there before the people listen to poetry
at 2:00 in the morning and I would go up
this is I'm talking 1999 I started 91
yeah so this has to be 91 92 because one
day they don't they told me not to come
back just don't come back you can't come
back there but I don't know how many
sets I did in there and really like just
wanted to get a bomb my guy was already
predetermined I'm just gonna be a
failure and I'm gonna go in there bomb
they told me then they closed the place
and I just I don't even know why I'm
telling you guys it just broke my heart
I took so many bombings in that place
they did that with the Boston Comedy
Club in New York when they closed it I
want it [ __ ] I thought it'd always be
able to come back there now isn't it
reopened no they read they they
recreated it for Pete Holmes his show
but they didn't reopen it it's a wine
bar I think no I don't know is it same
with it would laugh stops you laugh stop
in Houston
man when that place closed I was like
[ __ ] the original one the one yeah the
original one in you in in here a gray
yeah yeah yeah yeah great yeah I was on
gray Street oh my god they said when we
talked to Netflix and you know you don't
know your budgets gonna be when that you
get I mean I knew one gonna be much but
they said just ballpark well if you can
shoot your special anywhere
how would you shoot it no you know price
isn't an option I was like I'd go in and
I'd rent that restaurant for a week that
now is the Houston last stop and then
I'd rebuild this I'd rebuild the stage
it's still there what do you mean it's
not they never tore it down and the
restaurant closed and they only used the
front part for the restaurant so the
thing remains open they were opening it
for a few weeks
Jimmy Schubert did it they were opening
are you serious I'm comic talk them into
it but you couldn't cover the nut some
comic went in there and said listen it's
just sitting here it's there or you do
is going and put the lights on the whole
[ __ ] shine you're back on business
how does Comedy Central or someone not
shoot a bunch of specials in there like
just just a bunch of guys who started
there and grew up around there and and
like was it what was your home club said
well it wasn't that that was in from 97
to 2003 if you didn't work the livestock
you weren't [ __ ] as well no laugh stop
was the hip place to play and what
happened was Tom rode the show got
canceled and Mitch Hedberg talked him
into doing it with him a co-headlining
spot and that just leveled it out after
that yeah and stanhope went in there and
Rogan shot his CD and there are mice my
first yeah because they had the
capability to record yeah they would
tell you when you come in you want to do
a CD this week well paper for you really
oh you could say anything in that room
except George Bush George Bush don't my
wife that then you go to Austin go [ __ ]
the bushes they can suck my dick
when mrs. woo just died both of them
just yeah but the old man when the old
man valley you know it's really crazy
how you learn about geography and jokes
in the old days if you went to Austin oh
you could talk [ __ ] on the bushes is she
I remember going on the ride I remember
being up on stage in Houston [ __ ] lit
on Jagermeister doing quote from The
Godfather like after every two jokes I
would go I call the only that this only
did that and then I would do two more
jokes and go into biggie warning yeah
who the [ __ ] is this paging me at my 46
in the morn and crack it on and now I'm
yawn and in between those two things I
said every horrible thing I used all the
N words from biggie song I use law the
Michael Corleone's [ __ ]
and I remember I had him in hysterics
and I said some about George Bush and
the rumor just froze ha ha like you
can't recover in those days in Houston
from George Bush joke like political
Kanye died the slow death of it these
guys walking around today would have
been dying a slow death in there yeah a
little humor did you ever do the
Amarillo comedy club yes I did with the
Moran brothers no I knew the Moran
brothers I knew Kelly very Billy rest in
peace I known from Seattle before he ate
the pills or whatever the [ __ ] he did
because he always did something yeah he
was good friends with char dog and who
in turn was with my best friends with
Mitch Hedberg Mitch Hedberg and to chart
home and were the first people to ever
rent a Volkswagen bus and go across the
country doing guest sets really that's
how Mitch Hedberg yo-ho his work at
first
Kellie Moran and I work together at
Sacramento and laughs unlimited and the
lady there was Leslie was a Booker and
laughs unlimited and Kelly's like him
and you're really funny I was featuring
he does I need you to Tony town I'm
having a hard time following you I was
like oh sure man I'm of course so I dial
it very really cool he's sober at the
time so he we get done the first show
and he says - Leslie goes hey why don't
you have you should not have him
featuring I can't imagine there's a lot
of guys that can follow him you should
have him headlining she goes he's not a
headliner she goes he goes yeah he's
clearly a headliner and she goes no we
only hire headliners at headline other
places and he had a comedy club in
Amarillo and he goes hey what are you
doing that
weekend I said nothing and he goes would
you like to headline my club in Amarillo
I said I'd love to and he goes you're
hired
he's now a headliner don't let him
feature Kelly Moran did that for me and
I went down to I went down to Emerald
the very next weekend and I think if I'm
mistaken and I apologize but I think
Kelly got back on pills within the time
that I met him sober and that next
weekend he went into the Amarillo comedy
club he went into my backpack and he
took my joke book and he lit a cigar in
the back of the club and started smoking
a cigar in like a bagger Club and
flipping through my joke book and he go
uh gay Elvis dream what's that what's
that joke and I tell the joke and he it
was just him dying laughing in the back
smoking a cigar
he had his brother Kevin Moran I think
all of them were using pills Kevin had a
had broke his arm broke his hand he had
one hand that wasn't working so well but
he put 100 cigarette the the 100 length
cigarette in there he picked you up with
one of those burnin and he had a combs I
think he was eating pills and he'd comb
his hair with the other hand while he
drove and just just feather his hair cuz
it felt good she was high and he said to
me the first night I worked and then
their other brother I used to party with
all the time I forget his name
he passed as well but uh but man those
brothers were fun as [ __ ] and they they
were good
I worked there every quarter they
brought me back because I they like I
like to party and say these bring me in
and I remember Karen the first thing
says hey I don't care if you say the
n-word I don't care if you say anything
about Mexicans I don't care if you say
anything about anything
but if I hear one GD come out of your
mouth I'm pulling you off the [ __ ] was
the AG goddamn and then I remember the
farmer Pauly Shore went down there and
staged a fight do you remember that
Paulie for went down the Polish I went
down the amarilla comedy club this is
right when like all that [ __ ] like
myspace was big and he made it look like
he made a joke about rednecks and a guy
got off stage and punched him yeah and
he was sort of this door dude and and it
went viral and then he came out he's
like I staged it it didn't really happen
and everyone was like ah but I was like
that's it [ __ ] Amarillo yeah that
emerald come to cup that a bar right
next door me and Kevin and Kelly
youngest brother can't remember his name
um man we used to get a [ __ ] wasted
there and then Kelly's ex-wife would
come in that was her name
he's pull around really she's still
around sweetheart of a gosh she was
awesome we drink Coronas and she says
she was 20 in 1995 when Kelly was a
grown man yeah well we are not whether
she was in her my favorite choker hers
was she did uh excuse me I'm Janet Jack
let Janice Jackson wine at the time oh
do excuse me something it doesn't really
matter but I saw she painted Duncan for
a while no [ __ ] way
Dogen did [ __ ] a lot of people okay
milkshake to all those [ __ ] and then
Duncan seems like a nice guy but they
would show up and dunk him and make him
put balls in their mouth and do
diabolical [ __ ] and all these nice girls
were like [ __ ] about this Duncan's gotta
have a sick game Duncan's a sick
[ __ ] man but I came up with
Kelly and Kelly was a great guy than me
and whatever he's a great guy
what happened was he moved a light yeah
he was gone for about six months and
Here I am in Seattle cheering for him
you know cuz I didn't have the balls to
move to LA yeah I'm cheering for the guy
cheering for the guy cheering for the
guy he coming back to Seattle he goes on
stage on a Monday night ain't does the
exact same six minutes he left with and
I was blown the [ __ ] away I did a
thousand gigs of jelly
yeah Kelly used me as a feature in
Portland one time he was a great last
margaritas in Portland Oregon there was
a Mexican restaurant that was booked by
Donna Richards Kenny was his brother his
name's Kenny wait a second so I'm
telling you about that girl that I met
and I went with her for that oh yeah
yeah and then we're headed down to San
Francisco and she tells me she's really
good at doing that so I go wait till we
get for the hotel no guys well I'm
telling you this chick was perfect so
really pretty really sweet had a job we
start swapping spit I share comes
and she had a thousand of those skin
plugs what he called McKinney hikes skin
tags with the thing that's gross
yeah yeah yeah they were all over her
back so when you made out with her every
time you felt her back all she had was
those little skin grows and I remember
like her sucking my dick and me like
pecked her back oh [ __ ] like I'm going
to like a lump of thumbs it was like
going through a village of thumbs and
I'm stuck with this girl for four more
days and there was no electrolysis then
there was no like gold there was no
pickle Chinese lady on [ __ ] lifetime
that pop said [ __ ]
she had and then people saying Joe
hominy she probably had 18 on her back
but she hit him and she's like it's a
problem if it's a problem I'll get him
fixed like she had gotten dumped by
every boyfriend because of this thing oh
my god she's like all the guys I they
freak out Mitch accept a tremendous tube
she was the Sabbath it she was beautiful
and I said you know what I don't give a
[ __ ] you know I kept meeting her I'm
weekend yeah stuff and then I moved town
and I remember we spoke a few times and
she said she's gonna come visit me and
we was contact when that was it but she
had skin tags all over her back dude
when I was in first grade I woke up one
morning with a hundred skin tags on a
mower right first grade now now you know
I exaggerated stories I'm telling you I
was in first grade I had a hundred I
just woke up one day one day now you can
take those off my doctor doctor you take
them off yeah so I have a it's a hundred
and my mom notices on this is what is
this I don't know it just showed up so
they take me to a doctor on the first
grade and the doctor raised my arm and
I'm telling you every single one of them
he put a drip of acid on and it burned
him and it was so [ __ ] painful and
what's worse is it looked like raw meat
under my arms they all came off like
you'd ask them to put acid then clip
them off or whatever and I first grade I
remember I got I got just about any
present I wanted for like I remember I
got a Lone Ranger
action figure I got it I got the Stretch
Armstrong I got all this [ __ ] because it
was like raw meat under my arm and I've
never had them since but that I remember
just [ __ ] what causes those things
someone told me cancer they leave
friction or something it's it I get some
sometimes I'm gonna want my neck I don't
have any now no no a skin tag is
something that comes out you had those
things that come on hair grow out you
become an old mole a mole oh so much
worse is the skin tag yeah yeah she had
those every oh [ __ ] I'm trying to put up
that she's look at my nuts it was a
nightmare I hooked up with a girl with a
lot of moles and she was gorgeous but
just had a bunch of moles and you know
and she was she was probably a freshman
in college I was a junior for first
junior year second dude here right when
I was back from Russia and I hooked up
with her she had moles and she was
perfect but he says she was too young to
not know you got to get rid of those you
know like she was just a high school so
now you know it's like your parents
aren't gonna say [ __ ] you gotta be an
adult before you go how am I get rid of
this [ __ ] on my neck and so but I
couldn't I couldn't get past the moles
the moles are different than skin tags
go crazy when I have a similar thing
only I hadn't want film and TV credits
and that made it even more frustrating
because when I moved to this town the
guarantee was you shoot four episodes of
a TV show and now in the weekends you go
on you sawed-off yeah was that was that
simple yeah didn't need to know who you
were I didn't need to know what your
name was it was guaranteed when I first
started going on the road with Joe Rogan
the only [ __ ] people he used to walk
really I remember one specific argument
he got into me Kevin Chris McGuire
somebody came up and she goes you're a
fraud you're not Joe from Newsradio and
he's like are you [ __ ] kidding me
lady and she's like what you were saying
in there was you know misogynistic
whatever woman get pissed off about
and he told me it was what happened what
happened nobody picked you to play
handball yet the [ __ ] I mean Joe was
crazy to back these to get a lot of heat
back then because they want to see the
guy I can't imagine what America's
Funniest Videos guy did say it yeah god
he's going up there talking about
[ __ ] and babies and [ __ ] [ __ ]
the Olsen twins yeah that family you
know their families are they going to
see him I want to through the guy from
family videos you know the show is chat
falling off a bang and the Mexican you
show down there and this is what its
eliminated but to get back to the
original conversation I had the same
problem then and I didn't know what the
equation was nobody knows that the
equation was and I was just telling
these guys in a the other day that I was
doing a podcast for Felicia you know
we're just feeling out our way trying to
keep a topical no we agreed on nothing
topical so it couldn't be dated yeah so
we were talking and I couldn't figure it
out
and Felicia got those black things to
put in front of the microphone spit spit
catches yeah
and I'll never forget that I just went
to a story you're going to a story you
go into the story you're there for the
moment yeah
and I'm into the story and I'm talking
about mug and a hooker and that she did
a [ __ ] switchblade out when to cut
out an awesome wall three and my friend
started punching it and she was blocking
and she's like get me out of the car
I'll never forget looking at Felicia
[Laughter]
looking at her and her jaw was wide open
and she called me that night and said do
you really want to leave this story on
there and I know you know we don't have
that story on that podcast goes kaput
because yeah the half-hour after that
that's all we discussed that Sunday it
was 1010 of 10 $2 October 10th of 2010
yeah I was on a tape of CD itself I was
not prepared or a special in fact Damon
taped it I was not prepared
I just was taking a hunch and I put it
on the podcast that was tabled a special
I took 13 people would show up and I'll
never forget being in on the 101 of the
phone rang and it being sound on bro you
got 100 something people in there I'm
gonna sound why you lying company
doesn't know yeah you have 100 people in
there me walking in there I'm gonna tell
us the hooker and that was it
like there was that free year I had to
tell that story yeah three year I closed
that story in people [ __ ] some people
loved it and some people [ __ ] hate it
but there was no deviating from the
truth there's no deviation from you know
she got in the car she took a
switchblade out went to cut my buddy and
awesome we punch 210 times and I had it
raw like in the in the end the truth was
we were just try and take coke money
from yeah so she was a guy ain't giving
you my money and we took it to the
summertime we're gonna kill you right
now
and she goes okay and she opens up a
[ __ ] and out came a little ball like
that she took she took the you have any
bills on it she took her money and she
hid it into like a Chinese what's those
Chinese things that people play well uh
origami origami it was like thank you
look at 20 leave with the 20 this look
at this guy came out he covered his eyes
that hasn't seen sunlight weeks in
Jewish he came out he covered his eyes
who's on the twenty I think Hamilton was
black and wrapped no he's he's still
going Jesus Christ was I Alaska but we
she had the money this small like this
small and she goes you [ __ ] want
my money are you gonna have my money and
she opened up her legs and this fell out
of her [ __ ] and it was like a candied
you have those Christmas peanuts they're
like hours coated in like [ __ ] juice
and condom residue Oh [ __ ] afterbirth
and what I was
no [ __ ] and I remember we got in the
car and like we didn't want to touch you
were like alright let's go to the coke
dealers house and like going to his
house and giving the money and go ill so
we had to take the outside money and put
it in the middle it had the [ __ ] juice
and gradual district does that trick
Oh heads I win tails you lose
yeah was who's a rock crab oh yeah when
tell things I would tell you lose I got
a couple times the heads I win tails you
lose
further ah your special was phenomenal
uh-huh I wish you all the success I wish
you stay safe
I want you to promise me in the duel
will work out when you're on the road
yeah and not staying that thing you know
take care of yourself you know I've
never ever ever called you and help you
or anything because you know the reason
why I love you
you remind me a lot of my mother we says
to me I don't know I get that's not at
all [ __ ] there because I'm a
functioning [ __ ] addict even when I
was doing eight balls to 7:00 in the
morning and I was sleep you still gotta
go to work [ __ ] yeah
so I would get up and I'd still hear the
twitches of my neck okay we were talking
about last night it was Mercy's birthday
and we came over we you know at six
o'clock we got a Carvel cake she turned
six and we were talking about how I can
never pass a driving test do you know
that I have never officially passed
that's how stupid I the first license I
got it's like your brother home the
driving school yeah so all I did was
give him 50 bucks and he just gave me a
license second so I'd have to take the
driving test the written test yeah so
all I had to do is take the driving test
that's how I got my New Jersey license
but then my Colorado license I was
telling the Lee West like that Seattle I
failed four times
intense yeah and in Colorado I only got
it because I lived in basalt and
everybody would say go to go it's like
living in North Hollywood and having a
[ __ ] a DMV that's always empty yeah
but people would tell you go to one in
Hollywood even if it's packed because
the guy's an [ __ ] and you're gonna
fail anyway and I'm like I'm not going
to Glenwood Springs to take a [ __ ]
driving test I'm going to that guy yeah
and I'll never forget walking in there
and I walk in and there's a guy with
long hair and this guy's got all his
army medals in the back he's retired he
still got the Marine hairdo and the guy
came up to him like with the driving
test and he looked at he was well how
did you learn to SPRO and the guy's [ __ ]
you man it's true everybody says you're
an [ __ ]
I shouldn't became here so this is my
minute to act the guy goes [ __ ] you you
wanna fight he tells the old guy this
the old guy get something he's an old
man they got up this is a Marine
he got up like yeah I'll give it to you
and I got them in I'm like [ __ ] you punk
and I pushed her like throw him down the
stairs and [ __ ] we got into it then I
came up and I said that wasn't necessary
and I know I respect people you can't
hit people with white hair and all this
[ __ ] so you go shut up and taking a test
I mean the guy was just a tap alright
[ __ ] he was like the guy from the
platoon leader and what - yeah just the
same way yeah same attitude this year
isn't worth yours so once I stuck up for
the guy he after I took the test like I
had done okay is something I'm maybe I
got like 10 wrong and he goes I see how
he a drive it is so he took me and my
friend station wagon because you
couldn't you weren't allowed to bring
[ __ ] foreign cars then he would tell
you automatically that's how much of an
American he was your life don't bring a
chanc don't show up there with a Toyota
Nissan because he will fail you off the
bat don't even think it showed up with a
Hyundai ah because that's when 20 years
ago when Hyundai first came out white
people were
rampage like people like even father's
father because Honda built Meg's
the engines and Meg's that drove
Americans crazy during World War two
those Americans till this day still
believe that you know how many and when
I was selling Chrysler's I mean Jesus
came and said lift the engine on that if
they saw Hyundai there we go buy and
Hyundai's basically in every car really
there's a piece of a Hyundai and every
call Hyundai is the number one engine
build so you buy a Nissan it's probably
built by [ __ ] Hyundai I've never
owned and I've never owned an Asian car
so that's why all those old Americans
when they come in they would look at
Hyundai and gamma by no [ __ ] my dad
would never buy an Asian car because of
his dad yes I would and I know and I
just never bought nation I don't hate
Asians at all it's just a traditional
it's like it's a yeah you either get an
american-made car you could go German
that's what my dad said like not not
like let's set it down but my at data
either drove like a Lincoln or a
Mercedes I won't drive German I respect
for the Jews really yeah [ __ ] [ __ ]
drives the Volkswagen only in that way
my god if you love that BMWs me I still
hold the torch you understand me I'm not
even Jewish
yeah I hold the toy is rods for
mercedes-benz that's all I have I would
have a [ __ ] heart attack if like one
of my uncle's was in Auschwitz and you
showed up in my house with a BMW I would
[ __ ] kick you out of there I would
take it that personal mercy wash with
survivors on TV if I can just start
crying yeah like when they just being
there for the week oh so I don't want to
die and I don't have nothing as Germans
I just I don't like mingling Germans and
[ __ ] that's just a bad mango I don't
like when there's a German in the room
with a Nazi and I do in the room that's
the Exorcist
that's how the fight starts really
because one of the arguments starts over
when she comes down and pees that's why
she starts because the guy keeps calling
the guy a Nazi oh really in the act at
the beginning the first scene was nasty
not while they're playing the piano and
they're all singing the butler's is
German and one of the guests is Jewish
he's an actor
and he keeps busting his boss I wasn't
over there in the concentration camp
smallish [ __ ] he's doing that to the
Jewish kind to this to the German yeah
oh yeah finally the German guy takes the
Jew by the throat and chosen and then
that's a guy that falls off the window
he's a director and they couldn't figure
out who killed him they ruled out the
bubbler so it was the Exorcist because
they twisted his neck and then threw him
down the stairs there's no way a woman
could have twisted his neck so they
blame the butler but it was really Linda
Blair the devil really I don't know why
I'm telling you but you didn't finish
that driving story so you had the same I
got the station wagon he gets in the car
he finally starts warming up to me and
he does come on let's go off-roading
i'ma show you with some beautiful
country God's country and he shows me
these deer drinking [ __ ] water and
stuff I go way back he goes I'm gonna
give you your license you're cuz I start
telling I'm gonna be a Marine he kept
saying your wife I just finished robbing
the house two days there do you think
house and I'm like I'm here for
residency in Colorado and I'm gonna
become a [ __ ] marine and kill people
was like that's my boy you know he's
fine just yeah Alan races things like
just started yelling in the car like
kill everybody black Asian Spanish
people I'm sorry you know he was like
[ __ ] crazy one of those guys so
that's how I got my license I just
remembered that last night when I was
telling he's not much oh yeah I had to
take George is gonna be driving in like
six months four months they're crazy
George is gonna be driving I can't wait
have a [ __ ] designated driver call her
at 2:00 in the morning I'm at the store
come pick me up I got school the morning
go [ __ ] yourself I pay for that school I
buy you the car
yeah I can't I can't I can't let that
little kid Drive she's not ready for the
world
see Georgia she's a [ __ ] it would be
hard to start in LA she is such a [ __ ]
sweetheart and a good girl the day I
called you
yeah I was just watching her now where I
come from bark birthmark
why come from Bert when you see your
friends kids you get up you ask them how
they're doing and you buy them something
yeah you know I saw walking with a
little skirt on you know and I said Joe
hi Georgia and she turned around she was
like girl yeah you know I'm saying and
she waved at me and she's like hi and
like I just talked to your father I saw
what she was on you know but she was a
girl friends yeah I'm gonna be Uncle
Creepy because you called me yes I just
want you to know you got it you did a
great job with that girl yes I'm
watching it yeah she didn't always watch
it I was waiting for her to pop a
cigarette out to have a heart attack so
she was tutoring some girl like they
were looking at books yeah and she was
helping to go get to it and when I
wanted to pee I'm like I should pick up
her coffee or a screw she needs
something but I didn't want to think I
was being Uncle Creepy yeah so I didn't
say anything at all but I would do
anything for George I said to her I
think I called her that night I think I
was on the road I said hey did you uh
you see no no she goes she goes I was I
was at Murray I saw Joey I said you did
I said you say hi he goes yeah I said I
I said what was he doing she goes I I
think you were smoking marijuana smoking
cigarettes then yeah I would go over and
smoke a cigarette with one of the
writers there's a writer that goes down
always ask me so yeah I smoked the
cigarette with him yeah smoking
marijuana
I go yeah you definitely saw you again
for your daughter's at any point in your
life do you do you think a bottle when
you're on the road yeah I'm afraid
George is just such a sensitive like
really like Georgia is the kid for those
of you that don't know like I totally
sell stories about ila
but George is the kid that when when
mercy comes over to the house for
Christmas Eve
George attracts her the whole time stays
with her plays with her takes her into
the room remembers the [ __ ] that she has
little girl knows hey mercy we'll try
this hey why don't I come on hop up on
the thing and play the piano and mercy
also Mercy's a like a comet she comes
into that house and that is her home she
goes into islands room starts going
through her stuff just walks around
comes out talks to everyone makes
herself a plate sits up on her dad's lap
dude mercy as a comet she she's a lot
like she's a mix of Island Georgia isla
had that energy but mercy is also super
sensitive like very like there was
another little kid there this year and
mercy was taking the time to talk to her
make sure she's okay I can bang the head
at the end of the night know I'm sitting
that boom when you hit on a wood floor
just do the side of the cross I hope
that a my kid and the kid wasn't shot
you know but it's weird when she comes
over how mercy went it's not it wasn't
me no Georgia does take camera see
Georgia does has that sympathy I don't
give a [ __ ] I'll oh yeah I just got a
locked her door I go what are you doing
she goes Mercy's here
I gotta keep her out of my stuff dad I
go I'll open your [ __ ] door see the
but yeah the ILA
I'm Georgia is just so sexy she's gonna
get her heart broke really bad first guy
she falls on first guy she dates she'll
fall in love with and just get her heart
broke and I know that feelings I'm that
kind of person
and that's them be the [ __ ] we just
got to get her through that first
obviously if you don't know it Georgia
his you
oh we're not the [ __ ] two kilos yeah
Georgia's you without the T though she's
very level-headed I could tell that's
how you were when you were younger yeah
she does she walk to that [ __ ]
Mustang in the morning no you both your
eyes rather have no drama both of them
now I worry about my daughters and I
worry about what would happen
Oh worse he's gonna be so [ __ ] fine
that kid that kids got got that Oprah
gene we're like nothing's gonna hold her
back she there sir I mom reading this
book called coddling of American mind
and they're saying that the phrase that
kind of stuck with me was this phrase
about um this I guess guy that works for
Obama
when they're talking about kids being
oversensitive and getting outraged and
and he said I want to teach you to deal
with adversity I don't want to pave the
jungle for you I want you to be able to
figure out the jungle if I take all the
weights out of the gym it's no longer a
gym the weights are there because it
sucks and that's what you've got to do
and there's certain kids you need your
kids to find adversity and and I'll be
if I may I haven't made any mistake it's
been trying to protect my kids and not
let them run into as much adversity I
think that's a big fault of like the
kind of parent I am I think LeAnn shows
them more adversity says you know hey if
you want go to mentees you girls go by
yourself and I'm like no hit there's
kidnappers out there she's like they're
gonna be fine you did it when you were a
kid I love someone that could take
adversity on the chin and deal with it
and mercies that same person mercy is
she's got your gene
I don't think so mercy very sensitive
really if she runs around our parties
like literally like she's selling cars
like the what like she just is so rough
and tumble do you remember one of my
favorite stories is my favorite story
about your daughter
I've never we talked about this once
once a month this comes up with my
friends two Christmases ago I get I get
drunk super fast and I'm too drunk and
then so I go into my closet to take a
nap I take a 15-minute nap I disappear
for 15 minutes I wake up and I realize I
need to jump in the pool I need to get I
need to like sober up I'm gonna jump in
the pool so I throw on a speedo by the
way there's like 60 people in my house
right Joey's family our friends all the
kids I thought a speedo I come running
out and I jump in the pool and
immediately Isla jumps in the pool and
then this kid Carter jumps in the pool
and then this kid max jump to the men
Georgia jumps in the pool everyone turns
jumping in the pool and all of a sudden
you see mercy and she's looking at the
pool
and Joey goes are you gonna do it and
she Sprint's up to the pool and stops
and she goes no no no daddy it's too
cold and Joey goes come on mercy she
goes huh and everyone's no mercy and she
starts looking around almost like Hulk
Hogan like oh and then goes no no no
No and then turn see Joey smiles and
jumps into the pool it is so damn cold
what did you say before she what did she
say hold my ring she had clothes on
sneakers the whole thing and I don't
know hold things he goes okay daddy she
looks she looks he goes hold my ring and
she jumps II and we [ __ ] died
oh my ring place lost it you got to
realize there's 20 kids in the pool and
we got this one like fives five year old
on the edge I mean working the crowd
like Hulk Hogan like should I give him
the piledriver and everyone's like come
over it's easy go no no no and ever and
then all moms like you don't have to is
she's like looks at Joey hold my ring
and just jumps the place went [ __ ]
nuts I thought because she was at the
tip and she could see a little fingers
are moving she was nervous about it she
wanted to jump in
she had peer pressure on her she wanted
to swim you know she wanted to prove a
point but if he I know Mercy's little
head something was going on yeah and
finally she let us know hold the ring
forget the socks forget my underwear
forget the pants I got ya shirt the
jacket oh forget all that [ __ ] it's just
hold the ring dude that made us and then
add this year she came over and I go hey
Merc she's jumping in the pool and she
goes oh no she didn't know it was gonna
be as cold as it was she she jumped in
it's like 50 degrees she popped up just
you know that look you just
I worry about my mercy a lot I worry
about how to raise her holla you know
you see these girls in Hollywood and
you've seen you've been here a long time
yeah and you see that hole you see that
hole and you gotta figure out how to
fill that [ __ ] Hall you know yeah
woman come up to me and tell me they
want to be a star that's that that's not
normal you know there's gotta be a work
pattern the house
be all these things and this times I
like her at her school but this times I
don't like that's cool because of who
else goes to her parents and what
they're talking about saying to how Josh
quote said he pulled his kid out of the
school when he went to a kids party and
the alligator before he got killed was
that L Steve Irwin yeah he goes I went
to a kid's funk when they went the
carpenter yeah cuz I went to a kids
party and the guest was Steve Irwin with
the alligators there and he goes and
then I took my kid out of that school
when he had a party and they gave away
bags at the end a party favors yeah and
the kid looked at the bag and threw it
back at Josh he goes last party we went
to they gave us Nintendo's like the
games all it was expensive games yeah
and Josh is like I got polar otter then
I gotta pull him out of that this
environment that uh but I try the
toughen her up I show her narcos she
watches my clothes like me yeah I had
for watching uh Sopranos a little bit
she doesn't hit the curse word she won't
say him yeah cats been dead a week she's
hasn't said a word
my wife asked me tight what are you
gonna do I know you don't think she's
noticed it but she's noticed it she just
doesn't want to go there okay that's
fine what am I gonna do I can't force
her to go that cat has cats left in the
room every day all of a sudden he hasn't
been around she has not said a word yeah
it's weird how smart they are but she's
been talking about my mother really
really yeah yeah there was at the desk
she came into my office looked at my
mother's picture of me and she no dad I
gotta clean that picture and she took
the picture and I gave her a handi wipe
and that she doesn't add to the frame to
your mother likes it when you do the
frame I'm just looking like going god
damn it you know this is starting to
catch up on so I don't know what she's
put together
she knows her grandmother's dead but she
hasn't said [ __ ] about Harry in a
[ __ ] week who
Amy Schumer killed our hamster we was
along without movies no no a long time
ago was way before she was famous we've
done TV show together and I always liked
during she's a really sweet person and
Leanne and her got along and my sisters
got along with her and it was like you
know she kind of she kind of looks like
Georgia a little bit blonde hair and so
and so
Leanne we'll call her and say hey we're
going out of town for the month if you
want our apartments open we're gonna go
back to Georgia come out here use our
apartment the birth sisters are down the
street and you know yeah all I ask is
you watch the petal tight with a man I
would talk to her in nine years why I
don't know just I think people get
famous and they just is that what it was
was their disagreement know what I mean
this is a person that slept in the house
yeah yeah how the relationship with your
wife really really close relationship
with your children everything boy from a
coma her boyfriend will come over for
dinner
Anthony I know the one before that okay
and so so who we have the sick hamster
you got to give a shot to in order to
give a shot to the hamster you have
taken skin pinch it and that area pinch
you put it in the pinched area and so it
doesn't doesn't anyway Amy gives it a
shot and it's in the spine it leaves a
note of the tape oh the girls can't read
just no to the table hamster dead calls
me and I think I [ __ ] killed your
hamster I'm so sorry like no it's
totally fine you know it's not is it
totally get it it was a complicated
hamster that you got diabetes yet to
give it shots we got it it was not gonna
live forever so we take the hamster down
we're living in an apartment we could
find a little patch of grass where we
had buried other fish like you know so
we go to bury the hamster a little um
and Lyanna the girly-girl rolled enough
and Leanne says uh it's time say goodbye
to Cinderella and they go where said
about like going and we're like Oh
Cinderella's going to heaven and they're
like wait what's heaven and one like was
Cinderella's died
and she's going to heaven and I highly
ghosts do I know anything else that's
died and Leanne goes actually yes
shoes remember our cat Mufasa and not a
good yeah she goes Moo foster died and
Island Georgia goes wait wait wait
Mufasa is up at the hospital with
Grandpa Lee as I got grandpa's dead -
what's grandma grandma said everyone's
dead all these people over the hospital
they're all [ __ ] dead and they tell
they're like a lot of things are dead
girls yeah Amy was I used to be good
friends with Amy you know he met back in
New York and you Boston Common we did if
we did a show together for for common
central how many Central called reality
bites back me her Tiffany Haddish Theo
von Chris Fairbanks red grant Donnell
Rollins mo mandel Kyle sees and Who am I
[ __ ] forgetting Jeff Garcia was in it
and then one more there's one more than
forgetting I apologize what was a show
about it was it was we took every
episode we did a it was a reality show
but every episode parodied another
reality so in a comedic way so like
remember the show you think you could
dance so you think you can dance but we
did so you think you could dive and so
we did a diving competition that was
like a mash-up of the dancing we did a
The Bachelor but we did it with our moms
you know like it was like they parried a
parody everything it was interesting
because it paid a lot of money I want to
say it paid like 8 grand an episode or
10 grand an episode and we all got
excited but then when we got there we
realized if you got kicked off you no
longer made the money per episode so it
got oddly competitive so very quickly
like that very first episode everyone
stopped being friendly and started
competing except for like a handful of
us like Donnell red Amy me like a
smaller groups I think Theo none of us
got competitive we were all just chill
we were all hanging out and and she was
great man
I remember I was in Portland when
weekend and she walked up on stage it
just she was doing the theater she's
doing like the big theater I guess I'm
doing it this weekend but
you came in and hopped up on stage with
me and then we ended up partying at the
strip club next door going back to my
hotel room me her mark Normand my
feature and a couple people we met at
the club Jeff well wills from Live
Nation we all partied my hotel room and
then I met her at the airport the next
day there was a Sunday night we were all
met at the airport on Monday morning and
we drank at the airport flew back to LA
she was great man I think you just get
so famous that I don't know that I don't
know I really don't know I just haven't
talked to her to a guy like me there's
no explanation to it oh yeah but you
broke bread with me at one time listen
we can't be super tight yeah but there's
gotta be that twice a year call you know
in my world in my world even if they got
that busy where your phone yeah but
that's us that's us like I don't none of
us I mean think of how think of how big
Joe is I texted with Joe all morning at
maybe 20 tweets text back and forth to
each other that's and that's Joe he's
he's also got [ __ ] Elon Musk on the
podcast with with [ __ ] Kanye West
he's one of the biggest but we all text
to each other all non-stop I think
that's us
now is different you know like no no
this is oh no this is a story that I've
heard 200 times from 20 different comics
about 200 comics that have made it but
at one time they would tighten one in
phone then start ringing to their other
Williams gave all his friends 5,000 and
said lose my number that that blows me
away when someone says you go hey man
let me get your number I'll give you
text and they're like yeah you know what
call my assistant good huh yeah and
you're like I'm sorry existed I don't
need to talk to you know yeah I'm like
nah man not giving people that I put on
the podcast they've contacted me and
said when you do my podcast and I'll say
tomorrow okay my assistant no no no stop
right there yeah when I put you on my
bike as an age do not why people have in
the system want their assistant to do
everything I can't stand that
I can't it doesn't fly only [ __ ] with
the comics like my friends like friends
are guys I could call and it's not
uncomfortable you know if you make me
feel uncomfortable about call I call big
J this morning because he got trapped in
an elevator and he has footage of it the
big day got caught in an elevator last
night at Sirius XM I don't know for how
long but they I saw the Instagram post
and they had a camera viewing filming
the whole time and it's with a bunch of
strangers and I texted Django I need
that whole footage but like Bill burr I
can call I could just call him and be
like hey man what are you doing tonight
like that there are a couple guys that I
know that aren't like that I did just
and that's cool but I mean you're not
gonna be my friend you know if any more
I mean maybe when I was younger and I
thought I needed people to help me get
forward in the business you know but I'm
not like that if you're my friend you
know where I live
you you probably into my house you
probably in one of my parties you've
definitely seen me black out and you've
definitely seen gotten inappropriate
text from me you know it's crazy
probably the first friend I had in this
business was Segura I remember I
remember I remember not to get like
nostalgic but when I when when I had
that fallen out with that one comic you
know that kind of me we had a falling
out and I was doing the death squad
Chronicles or ice house Chronicles and
me and you were getting coffee all the
time and I remember one night I met I'm
at the ice house and I'm getting ready
one stage we just on the Ice House
Chronicles and Tom had said to me him
and you need to like open up like you
know Joey's a great guy or he's great
guy Joe's great guy they don't you know
like they're all trying to like they're
all trying to reach out to you and
connect but you're really distant I had
a thing where I was like I don't I
didn't trust anyone at that point I just
didn't trust people I didn't trust
people and I was like I don't need
friends I'll just this is work I don't
need friends this has worked and Joe
came up to me at the ice house he had a
shot of Jack and a beer and two beers
two shots of Jack - two beers I'm
getting ready to go on stage
I just got high I'm a little buzzed and
he gives me the shot and he goes hey
you're a really good guy and we're all
trying to be your friend and I was like
cool I'm just shut off I'm like cool
he's no I don't think you're hearing me
like we're all trying to be your friend
and you just let us be your friend you
know we could all be friends
and I was like okay and he goes you
understand what I'm saying like me
Joey Ari Tommy we're all trying to be
your friend let's be yeah lighten up and
I was and and everyone knew that I was
shut off
you knew it cuz you were like hey we're
having coffee every day for every
morning for a month as long as you're in
town every morning we meet for coffee I
took that shot I got in my Buber to go
home that night and I thought I really
thought about it driving back from
Pasadena go I'm you know you're a little
high on that ride because you're buzzed
and I was like I don't really have even
Tom wasn't my friend anymore I'd shut
everyone off and I was like you know
what I'm gonna be vulnerable and let
people be my friend and you were you
were the very first one where we at
where I told you I was now going to
therapy and you're like [ __ ] that
[ __ ] every morning Maria see me
and you and me and you hung out every
single morning for the entire month of
October leading up to November 3rd so
November 3rd I had a birthday party that
you guys all came to I was turning 40 I
was 39 years old and every morning we
had coffee and I was like and I remember
someone saying I was leaving called the
parents from our school were there and
then who you were there that's my friend
Joey and I was like I just called some
of my friend and then Jose I can't want
you come out to my daughter's birthday I
came up there Tommy's like hey man we
need to start hanging out more I was
like yeah and then Ari is like hey we
should do a trip together and lands like
you you need that and it it all sudden I
just opened myself up to my friends do
it
it changed my life it changed my life
entirely and so when I now when I look
at things like when I look with Amy I
don't have anything negative to say
about her I'm not I'm not mad at her but
like I don't know I'm not probably ever
gonna be her friend you know because I
look at and I go I want people that were
cool for good like I can [ __ ] up and
you're still gonna like me I can I can
say the wrong thing and you're not gonna
like judge me you know I've said [ __ ]
horrific [ __ ] to Bill burr where he just
goes yeah that's Bert you know it's so
funny you know I just I guess you get
older in this business you go a
big J texted me not to out big J like a
year ago he texted me goes I'm so glad
we're becoming friends you know like his
really means a lot I think you're a
really funny guy and you're fun to be
around
do not I fluent the last time I flew
into New York I'm supposed to fly in
Monday and big J texted me he goes hey
if you fly in Sunday we go to my buddy
Wayne's house and we watch internet
videos and just get high if you want and
I was like I'm flying this Sunday I'm
gonna hang out with big J
it was [ __ ] beautiful it's the best
thing Mansa it's so nice do you member
the time one of my favorite memories of
you ever do you member the time it was
like it was a fall night as a fall
evening you guys had mercy was maybe
like one maybe two and you called me
I'll be like what are you doing
I said I'm sitting my front yard with
the girls having a glass of wine you go
I'll be over at five you and Terry came
over with mercy me and you sat in those
Adirondacks and all girls played on
blankets I smoked a cigar and we had a
class one and it was like [ __ ] yeah I'm
so glad I have friends [ __ ] is so
meaningful in this acquaintances this
friends then you have your brothers then
you have your comedy brothers
yeah your comedy brothers are very
important I can't turn on them you can't
have any animosity towards them you
really have to be happy for them and
you're not gonna have 20 of them you're
not gonna have 20 of them you lucky of
you got three or four yeah you know it's
like I told you when you came in before
the podcast I told you in front of your
father I looked at you're torn I'm
concerned yeah a little concerned you
know I know you're gonna make money and
I gotta make my answer that's not my
concern my concern of those two little
girls in the house yeah follow me I want
you to think big picture everything is a
big picture you need that in comedy
myself and Joe Rogan height nothing
bothers me more when people ask me for
something for Joe wrote well because
they do not understand the reason why
we've stayed friends
is because I've never gone over that
line there's a line in Hollywood and
since people do it to us all the time
when one of our own trying to do it to
us it cuts like a knife yeah you know I
had a situation last week where I
contacted somebody and I said I want to
do
something the next thing you know I'm
headlining their show hell I'm like I
was doing it for free and you put my
picture on this thing can't do that
you know treachery the people around you
can't you have to be friend you know Tom
Lee needs that you need that we can't be
you have to be able to call me on savvy
know hey man and I talked to you about
something I'm at this club with this
manager and he told me last night I
didn't sell out but the whole back
people were standing and you know you
need that yeah I had Ralphie for years
oh yeah right we Saturday no matter
where he was I got a call from Ralphie
at 8 o'clock wherever he was and we
talked for 10 15 minutes and that was my
therapy for the week I knew I couldn't
have many more than that and I'm saying
yeah I mean Ralphie got huge he never
threw me out to the dogs
no ruff you as big as roughly got
mariga's Ralphie guy he called me up go
I just made some barbecue sauce player
wine we get the families together
just come over you know an hour late I'm
not getting Ralphie I hate a Mercy's
crib I just know when we're calling him
one time with a flat tire just going I
just don't have the 30 bucks yeah and he
goes where are you and I Tom over here
and he goes sit tight the next you know
a tow truck camp took it the Firestone
and when I picked it up there was four
new tires
no I meant Long's he was like an Alabama
yeah you know and they never mentioned
it to anybody didn't say on the podcast
embarrass me
that's what comedy friends do especially
when one lifts one of us is always gonna
let one of us is doomed to be Kevin Hart
and I say doomed doomed one of us is
gonna be doomed to be Amy Schumer
yeah one of us might be doomed to be
louis c.k I'm not talking about sexual
references or in it I'm talking about a
comic with a target on your back
difference that's what happens between
being a comic and there's a different
being a comic with a target on your back
man I don't think I don't think anyone's
had a big maybe Louie's target right now
but Amy's target
Jagannath Carlos Mencia was huge all the
only comical made out alive with
Seinfeld yeah like he's the only one
that without a son said don't make him
53 million a year still doing what he
does every year but when you have that
when you attacked me in the mob boss you
were my boss yeah no matter what Lee
does you're responsible for it when you
have that target on your back I never
got into this business to have that
target on my back I'll stay I'll be very
comfortable staying right under the
radar right well let me do theaters this
size for like two more years I'll be
cool and if I go back to clubs I'm very
cool with that that's why I said to you
about the garden I don't know I didn't
think about that way and I think if I
think about I'm thinking about the whole
experience
yeah well it doesn't really matter where
we sit Lee because we're gonna be
watching him on the monitor I don't like
that sentence well I don't like that
sense those tickets are a hundred and
sixty dollars I'm gonna talk about to
bash I'm talking about anybody in
general I wish only the best for
Sebastian I always think of that brick
wall that's what comedies about yeah and
somewhere along the line we tricked it
the agents tricked it it became more
about money again the reason why you
became a comic job Burke was not to have
a day job when you go on these long
tours it becomes I never want here for
it to be a job I thought the comics keep
your [ __ ] nut low because some day
your numbers are gonna go well now
you're gonna have to go up yeah it's a
big difference than going out and a
happen to the law what I have to know I
saw what I saw it would Bobby Slade with
that big house in the mouth it went from
him going out and having a great time
and drinking to going out to keep the
lights on in the house that's not good
that's a job so it's always great to
have friends and comic friends I want
the friends I have I like Joe because
Joe Tommy when I'm slip
I do the same for joe yeah joe and i
come from complete two different
backgrounds we both have the same
passion to stand up that's why me and
Joe France because we both respect it we
respect it you know I've learned how
much have we learned and Joe how luckily
to have a guy like Joe yeah you know I
was the one that told him about Sunday
I'm him when he had the baby I said to
him that Sunday [ __ ] ain't gonna work
[ __ ] you I'll do peel because there's
nothing like [ __ ] family dinner on
Sunday and I started doing it when I was
dating Terri remember the first three
years I did it Terry I'd come back New
Year's Eve and I'd do the Comedy Store
let's see her that night and then always
way that I was back on the road again
with no whatever who cares when I was
coming home and one day I got home I
think three or four years into it I
worked at rocky Laporte in Dallas and
that Sunday was the longest Sunday of my
life that all week was just a long
[ __ ] week working with that guy
telling me what the same would not to
say how to say it and then Sunday came I
never forget waking up that Sunday going
that Monday morning and doing this is
the last Sunday I've been working again
and I've never worked the Sunday since I
was a featurette I was a feature and I
made up my mind oh and before the
podcast world started getting big the
funny bones called me and made me an
offer
Wednesday through Sunday 1500 no plane
ticket and I'm gonna call them back and
going how do all the weeks but you got a
home it's Sunday and they go well then
we'll give you 1,200 I go what to the
Fallen long plane taking I'm walking
with eight and I ain't selling t-shirts
you think I'm gonna sit back there with
the [ __ ] glasses no and I said no I
rather not well you know you have to
stick to your decision in this business
and once you go back alley now we got in
this conversation I really don't matter
[Music]
yeah when does the World Tour start
starts tomorrow in Portland and it ended
June 29th and [ __ ] in Siberia and I
think they were trying to get a ten in
my
scowl really yeah what has happened is
really hard to do business and rush yeah
it's really hard I was like yeah do it
Moscow get a bunch of you it'll fly out
do a small club so you're gonna end in
Brisbane you're gonna have a huge
audience in tenth planet and Brisbane
all the farmers lived there
yeah so I'll let Frankie barking no you
come and don't bring you some [ __ ]
reefer yep okay good carry you you're
doing Minneapolis you got Green Bay I
got that gravano Ottawa City
Indianapolis Bank New Jersey look at you
sold out the first one Philadelphia
where you at in Philly
I mean can Keswick I think as Keswick
just outside Philly you doing then tuck
it do I know I don't think so
that's Carolinas you know it's Fox with
Mashantucket oh yeah oh yeah yeah doing
Foxwoods Boston Boston Charlotte look
Travis --n go to a [ __ ] Burt Burt
Burt calm is that it Burt Burt Burt calm
came buddy I hurt Burt that trauma to
your wife's is pepper but yeah there's a
you get all those first shows sold out
but there's tickets available for most
other second shows so I'm happy it came
out today bro I love you joking but look
I'm at the Brea improv January 24th
through the 26th that's all I got in
January then February I got one nine
treasure round in Vegas the 22nd the
23rd I'm at the Fox Theater I think in
Tucson and Valentine's Day
I'll see you [ __ ] up in San Jose
at original [ __ ] Joe's like a
doctor all right I want to thank my
crazy I want to thank the [ __ ]
most importantly I want to thank you
guys for all the love and support that
you give us don't forget I'll be at the
Bray improv January 24th through the
26th I've put up my 56 and still
slinging dick post up a lot of you guys
again
tickets thank you very much for the
support but don't forget the church
what's happening now also has support
and one of those companies is Robin Hood
and I love them my wife loves them Robin
Hood is an investing app that lets you
buy and sell stocks EF etf's options and
kryptos or Commission free
they strive to make financial services
work for everyone not just for the
wealthy simple and intuitive with a
clear design with data presented and an
easy to digest way like I told you my
wife signed up for Robin Hood and she
thinks it's the best thing since sliced
bread all right there's no Commission
fees there's no course other brokerage
charge up to $10 for every day trade but
but Robin Hood doesn't charge nothing
who gots you trade stocks and you keep
all the profits it's easy to understand
charts and market data place a train in
just four taps on your smartphone four
taps Robin Hood web platform also lets
you view stock collections the 100 most
popular sectors of entertainment and
social media and curated categories like
female CEOs and analysts ratings of buy
hold and sell for every stock listen
you're sitting there going uncle Joey I
don't know nothing about this well
you're gonna learn you're gonna learn
how to invest as you build your
portfolio that's why uncle Joey's here I
didn't have a portfolio when I was 20 or
30 you could do something different
about it and start now with Church go to
church dot Robin Hood dot-com you
discover new stocks and you track
favorite companies with personalized
newsfeed custom notifications for price
movements so you never miss the right
move you guys know timing is everything
so what I'm gonna do is this Robin Hood
is giving the church family free stock
like Apple Ford sprint to help you build
your portfolio sign up at church dot
Robin Hood com
that's church dot Robin Hood Tom listen
I ain't gonna [ __ ] tell you people
again the NFL playoffs are here
[ __ ] college basketball is here
hockey's here I mean there's so much to
bet on I got two cockroaches in the
alley they're going off at [ __ ] five
minutes listen you got it's time to get
in on the action with my bookie don't be
that guy sitting around like a [ __ ]
Mook while your friends and family and
dip in [ __ ] onion dip potato chip put
money in their pocket not this year it's
Super Bowl 53 and it's right around the
corner I think on February 4th you can
start making money now so by the time
the Super Bowl comes
your bankroll is [ __ ] on fire you
understand me and you could bang the
house and you can [ __ ] not do nothing
the whole month of March your smoke
cigarettes and have little midgets come
over and suck your dick make sure you're
ready for the daily action by signing up
at my bookie today they pay fast when
you win ownership really cares about
good customer service and they offer the
craziest props where you bet is just as
important as who you're betting on and
if you want to make money during the
bowl season you got to go to my bookie I
trust them but you have to take my word
for it check them out for yourself what
I'm gonna do is this join today right
now and my book you will offer you 50%
deposit bonus to make sure you got a
nice little bankroll to start the bowl
season you understand me use promo code
Church CH you are CH when you deposit to
activate the offer that's promo code
Church listen go with my bookie you play
you win you get paid or like a
[ __ ] another sponsor I want to
thank is 23 and me 23 almost everybody
is born with the ability I did jet
listen forget all that stuff we now live
in a world where we have access to data
and they give us more personal insights
on who we are where we are and where we
came from I mean little things like how
we sleep and how many steps we take a
day shouldn't our health resolutions be
customized also 23andme allows you to go
beyond the ancestry to access more
personalized insights based on your DNA
from health predispositions to lifestyle
choices with the 23andme health and
ancestry crit you get over 90 reports on
your health traits ancestry and more
reports include lactose tolerance
caffeine consumption muscle composition
genetic weight report I mean listen I
didn't I found that I was not but top of
Spain I'm west bank Africa I got a
little Jewish in me I got a little
Chinese in me you know this is
interesting stuff okay you can meet
relatives on there you can see where
your cousins are through a timeline
23andme has it all what I'm going to do
is this by your 23andme help ancestry
kit today at 23andme
doc Tom's last Church that's number two
three and me.com slash church again that
23andme calm slash Church
I want to thank 23andme I want to thank
Robin Hood and I want to thank my bookie
for having our back and always being
there for us and most importantly you
guys I love you doll my heart it's a
pleasure and honor to be able to come
here twice a week and talk to you
[ __ ] savages like I am your uncle
cousin reality I'm the best [ __ ]
uncle you got again I want to thank Burt
I want to thank the [ __ ] my
main man Lisa at who [ __ ] destroyed
last night in the Comedy Store I want to
give him his props garnet even [ __ ]
hit me up this morning and said Lee did
very [ __ ] him well that he went to
this floor just to see Lee so I want to
congratulate him but most important I
want to thank you guys for always having
our backs supporting my toys and
listening to the podcast you know I'm
sincere and I mean it from the heart
without you guys I got who got so do me
a favor
enjoy the podcast have a great weekend
and we'll see you Monday morning tip top
Magoo ready to [ __ ] go all right kick
this [ __ ] melee